today the Supreme Court ruled the Biden
Administration is allowed to remove
border barriers in Texas and now a
Louisiana rep says that Joe Biden is
staging Civil War by pulling down
Texas's border barriers in Texas
Democrats are proposing a solution
federalize the Texas National Guard
basically have the FED seize control of
a Armed Force in the state that is
opposing their facilitation of human
smuggling yo man hey I know everyone
saying Tim said Civil War no a Louisiana
rep said Civil War so we'll talk about
that plus Ronda santis has endorsed
Donald Trump this is uh this is
fantastic so I'm really excited to talk
about that and uh Trump says RI San
demonius is officially retired no longer
they will use that name and then of
course I think the most important story
Shan stri Strickland got robbed at UFC
297 he should have won he did win
someone asked me they were like oh who
won the fight and I was like Strickland
did and I was like oh cool yeah but they
called it for dupi but we'll talk about
all that I'll just generate some
controversy beforehand I think dupi did
great I'm not a big UFC guy so I don't
know a whole lot about it but I was very
disappointed to see that ruling you know
Joe Rogan expressed shock at the ruling
Dana White said Strickland won and the
reason why I am I am salty about this is
Strickland Covington these are guys who
are coming out and they are standing up
for the little guy they are pro athletes
who are speaking up and it's about time
we had some of that and then I watched
this fight where a guy clearly wins but
then they call for the other guy and I
just feel like it's all staged it's all
fake so we'll talk about all of that
before we get started my friends head
over to cast brew.com to buy cast Brew
Coffee why should you it supports this
show and it's the best coffee you'll
ever have I have to say at this point
the amount of sales we're doing of
Appalachia nights ground it's already
sold out I can't believe it's sold out
now I feel bad and our coffee pods are
sold out okay now I'm feeling real bad
but hold on on appalachin kns whole bean
is still available for those that want
to get it man even our whole bean rise
with robberto JR is sold out guys we are
selling way too much of this coffee I'm
I I didn't even realize these things
were sold out but uh if you want to
support the show go to Cas brew.com buy
our coffee and as you can see the stuff
really is good uh we're selling
thousands of bags every every week I
think and uh I really do appreciate your
support the coffee shop is in isn't
under construction aiming for a June
opening that's a hard hard date so we're
really excited for this and if you want
to support our work you can we sponsor
ourselves at Casper but also head over
to
timcast.net
but come on there's not going to be a
super Tuesday whatever it'll be it'll be
something but we're going to have a live
show in West Virginia and if you like
that we're putting on these live shows
and the work we're doing it's possible
because you guys guys become members and
support us directly our cultural
Endeavors the products we're building
the parallel economy all the stuff we
support is made possible when you become
a member and you will get access to the
uncensored members only show which will
be coming up tonight at 10 p.m. where
you as a member can actually call in to
talk to us and our guests we'll take
your questions but make sure after you
sign up become a member you join our
Discord server where you can hang out
with like-minded individuals and then uh
you have to submit if you want to be
some of the people who are asking
questions cuz we only take about 5 every
night but sign up support our work smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else is the great Roger
Stone Tim thank you very much for having
me I'm delighted to be here I think
everybody already knows who you are but
I must ask you to introduce yourself uh
let's see I'm a veteran of 13 National
Republican Presidential campaigns I'm a
New York Times bestselling author uh I'm
a Believer in Jesus Christ uh a soldier
in the army of of the Lord uh I do a
Daily Show at stonezone decom also a
radio show at WABC radio on Sundays in
New York uh and um I have a lot of
political opinions I've been in the
business 45 years with the uh New
Hampshire primary coming up tomorrow
there's a lot of news related to this
Biden's not on the ballot he's also
being challenged in Illinois and you're
going to have a lot you you have a lot
of insights for us on this to explain
what's going on so thanks for being here
it should be a lot of fun we got Hannah
Clair bro hanging out hey I'm Hannah
Clair bremelo I'm a writer for cnr.com
that's scanner news I'm really happy to
be a part of that team Ian's here of
course hi everyone Ian cross and happy
to meet you Roger what um well I guess
we'll get into on the show I'll ask you
more about your your career once we get
into it we got Serge to my right here yo
I am surge.com
uh best uh I guess good match to uh
Strickland he's a great dude uh I'm
wearing my South Africa Jersey because
uh I'm soaked South Afric is getting up
in the world we got Mr Mr Beast he has
he has no choice but to support dup yeah
right Mr Beast a girlfriend in sou
African a guy won this this Championship
I don't know what the championship was
honestly but uh Elon Musk we got a lot
of South Africans I think it was
middleweight yeah middleweight and you
know what shout out Bill Tong is based
AF it's delicious and I think dupi did
absolutely fantastic it was a great
fight but I just felt like Strickland
won but we'll talk about that we will
get into it heavily because uh Dana
White is pushing back on some woke
reporters who are who are calling out
Strickland speech but uh let's jump into
the first big news here from the post
millennial Louisiana rep says Biden is
staging Civil War by pulling down Texas
border barriers Texas should stand their
ground Higgins posted this of course is
is in response to breaking news that the
Supreme Court will allow federal agents
to cut Razer wire Texas installed on us
Mexico border it was a 5 to4 ruling
leaving many people shocked Texas is
being overwhelmed there's a story I
don't know if it's true but I'm hearing
uh uh Mayor Johnson in Chicago is having
panic attacks or is that true did you
hear that check Google search see if you
can find that because I heard people
talking about on Twitter but we know
know that the mayor the mayor of Chicago
New York they are freaking out over the
massive influx of illegal immigrants On
the Border we know it is the worst we
have seen at least in my lifetime and
it's substantially worse than anything
we've seen in the past decade and so you
have Texas desperately trying to stop it
deploying armed soldiers of the Texas
National Guard to block federal agents
from being able to control the
jurisdiction in this area and now the
Supreme Court has ruled in favor of
federal agents this to me looks like a
Sumpter esque type scenario where the
federal government is asserting
jurisdiction over an area the state is
rejecting it the state has deployed
armed n armed soldiers and the FEDS are
now countering we're hearing a lot of
crazy rumors but this does feel like uh
uh it could be escalating to this
Federal versus State conflict and with
as many states as we've seen who are
upset over the massive influx of illegal
immigration and the fact the Biden
Administration is facilitating this I
think I think we're walking on on on the
razor ere
uh all I can see is that the federal
government is intentionally letting
immigrants in to later repatriate or
patriate them I guess give them
citizenship to go fight in a war that
they're anticipating I don't understand
other than that to shift the census data
right it's to say there are this many
people here and that's why we should get
extra representation in the government
even though they're not here to legally
vote they didn't enter this country
legally I mean the implications of
illegal immigration are really serious
and I think uh the federal government is
actually pushing Texas to more ser
iously consider secession they have that
vote coming up to consider it uh in
November I think they're going to
isolate themselves from what is
ultimately a small country that we're
all attached to I mean Texas is
independently economically viable
without the US the look it is the policy
of the bid Administration to have open
borders period Joe Biden himself blurted
it out three days ago he said when they
asked him point blank is the border
secure he said no and I've said that for
a number of years well he needs to tell
that to secretary mayorcas plus Jean M
Jean Pierre because that's the exact
opposite of what they have said notice
what the mayor of Chicago said he said
this is not sustainable we're going to
run out of money soon because we don't
have the money for the Social Services
for this influx of migrants and the
answer is to give them citizenship H how
is that the answer uh when when
secretary blinkin uh met with the
president of Mexico in their joint
communic he also implied that the answer
was somehow to give this influx of
Migrant citizenships well we understand
that would allow them to vote perhaps
that's the goal but I don't see how that
will solve the the fiscal uh problem the
the the fentol problem the crime problem
the fact that these cities these
counties these States they're running
out of money they don't have the money
to sustain this influx of of migrants I
think the money they're looking for is
to facilitate more of it we've seen for
years they've been putting UND they've
been smuggling children on planes and
and transporting them across the country
mhm so we we've you know it's funny when
we have a Democrat come in here and we
show like Mar Williamson we show her the
story it's like this from 2021 where
undercover video catches them doing this
they're smuggling people they're getting
away with it the thing about just
getting them into vote which they might
be doing to make give them citizenship
and let them vote is like they could
just use electronic voting machines and
flip tallies and like cheat the voting
systems if they really wanted to
guarantee a vote outcome they don't need
to destroy the system within within
immigrants so I don't understand there's
got to be more than it's a long-term
solution as opposed to a short-term if
they were to flip votes that's shortterm
if you're to bring in people promise
them public coffers n offer them
executive order citizenship or something
which I think Biden will probably try to
do at the end of the year I think
there's a strong probability of it then
you will get a longer term voting base
but it's more it's more than that it's
that putting these people into cities
increases Democrat Democratic members of
Congress so if these people go there the
next time we have a Census count which
is I think what it's going to be six
years correct no years how many how many
seats will the Democrats get from
non-citizens regardless of whether these
people vote and how many Electoral
College votes will they get regardless
of if these people vote the idea is to
just change the basic makeup of the
American electorate look my my sister's
son my nephew her only son uh who lives
here in West Virginia died of a fental
overdose late last week 38 years old s
has touched my family
directly it it's a horrific tragedy uh
but but that's what these policies are
giving us and this Administration
doesn't seem to care in fact they seem
to be promulgating it I think it's just
you know it feels like the unraveling of
the country intentionally like a if we
can't have it then we will burn it down
if we can't have it no one can kind of
thing like a deranged uh stalker
ex-lover who's upset that his girlfriend
moved on so he's like if I can't have
her no one can they're just they're just
destroying everything cuz they're mad
Trump's going to win or perhaps
more pragmatically they are concerned
that Donald Trump will win and they will
go to prison so they want to destroy
whatever they can to make sure they
weaken the machine which will once once
Trump is elected will be turned against
them did you maybe I mean the other
thing is that they didn't maybe they
never valued the country before right
they never valued America at any point
and so the idea that they're like we
don't care that this is destroying
anything because we never thought it was
worth protecting or saving they can't
see why America is a unique nation and
why importing fentol into poor parts of
the US is a disaster right there's sort
of an elitism about it that says this is
not something I I care about because it
doesn't touch my life and in fact I
don't value this I mean it was always
what celebrities were like if Donald
Trump gets elected I'm moving to Canada
it's the same type of mentality I can
leave this behind even if you die from
him but you even have liberals like Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City who
runs for mayor saying he's proud that
New York is a sanctuary city today he's
saying this threatens to destroy New
York As We Know It uh these Mayors they
don't know what to do they can't they
can't provide the social services
required uh and people who are legal
residents are being denied social
services so we can house uh uh you know
migrants now here's my concern you
already have armed National Guard armed
soldiers deployed to block federal
agents the Supreme Court has now ruled
in favor of these federal agents they
can go in and remove Razer wire
basically allowing wave after wave of
Criminal Alien entering this to enter
this country
the Texas National Guard is already
defying the feds the feds have asserted
jurisdiction here Texas National Guard
said screw off what's going to
change why would the Supreme Court
saying you can remove the razor wire
change anything about Texas state law
and how they handle law enforcement
Texas has said it is illegal to cross
our borders in this way and we will
enforce the law the feds are saying we
can remove this and allow them to break
the law I don't I don't see Texas
backing down from this Texas is going to
say that's great Supreme Court really
really great good luck removing the
razor wire when our guys are standing
there holding guns blocking you from
access to the river what's what are the
feds going to do show up with guns and
point the guns at the National Guard and
say get out of the way is the is is
Texas I mean fair fair question is Texas
going to instruct their armed soldiers
you must now evacuate and let the feds
come in because it's the order is uh
it's a temporary order pending the the
ongoing litigation is there a chance
that like effectively Tex could be held
in contempt of court like what are the
punishments for not going along with
this temporary order pending ongoing
liation what does that even mean when
the feds have already asserted
jurisdiction on on the river and Texas
said f off you you you can file all the
paperwork in the world for injunction
the feds have already asserted it's our
jurisdiction and Texas said don't care
get out with guns so the only option now
is either the the only paths forward
would be Texas backs down and says we
hereby respect the Supreme Court
we are going to remove all of our law
enforcement we are going to allow wave
after wave of criminal aliens to break
state law and do nothing about it or
they're going to say this changes
nothing it's illegal in our state we
don't care if if if the feds think
otherwise I mean that's what Paxton said
attorney general Ken Paxton said you
know this is this is a temporary order
and the litigation is ongoing and we're
going to continue to fight this I mean
he's not saying exactly what they'll do
if they'll refuse to let them take the
razor wire out but he is saying that
Texas is not willing to put up with this
sort of uh Federal reach their border
security so what are the fed's going to
do
next uh nothing this this is a classic
struggle between Federal power and
State's rights uh but while we're
sitting here trying to sort this out how
many million more people are going to
come into the country illegally and my
fear is that let's say Donald Trump wins
in November handily Joe Biden rubber
stamps an executive order granting a
quick path of citizenship for all of
these people Millions at at that point
would be what 12 to 15 million people
and then there's instant instantly
people say we're suing we're going to
challenge this and he smiles and says
yeah in two years when this is resolved
those people will have already gotten
their papers good luck resolving it I
think we need to set some precedent
about how awful uh horrendous unethical
illegal that would be for a president to
by decree give people citizensh you mean
like daaka yeah some Mass swipe of the
pen you mean like it's already been done
like Obama did with the dream with
dreamers if it's been done before yeah
this kind of thing cannot we can't let
that stand that's insane that would be
insane and now imagine this scenario Joe
Biden let's say it's November 25th Trump
is president-elect Joe Biden rubber STS
an executive order saying we're going to
secure the Border but the compromise
will be all the people who are here are
granted a standard path to citizenship
which will take 3 to 5 months you mail
your form it's mailed back you sign it
you send it back in you're a citizen
you'll get your
paperwork and then come next year it's
challenged in the courts finally makes
it to scotus scotus says
unconstitutional and moves to revoke
citizenship from 15 million people who
are previously illegal immigrants Donald
Trump as President says we are going to
remove these people who enter this
country illegally and were only granted
citizenship under false pretenses the
left then says look at all the videos of
trump rounding up American
citizens and putting them in
camps D Eisenhower deported 1.3 million
illegals it it can theoretically be done
uh and as you have a deteriorating con
condition in the country in terms of
crimes drugs uh Economic Opportunity and
so on uh I'm not sure that uh the
Democrats would be on the popular side
of this also I'm not sure the
constitutionality of Joe Biden waving a
wanding saying well you're a US citizen
I'm not sure you can do that what about
Daka look I'm not a lawyer so I'm not
I'm not I don't think it's legal but I
mean
Obama executive order was a a what do
what does Daka stand for can you look it
up for um deferred action on child
childhood arrivals right and so This Is
How They inch
forward uh uh they say okay well you
know if you were here as a kid it's not
your fault so we're we're going to give
you a path to citizenship and there's a
lot of people who only know America they
don't know any other country and so then
what happens is people on the right
compromise a lot of conservatives don't
but many on the right will be like okay
fine fine we'll stop there though the
next step is Joe Biden's going to say
it's been a crisis it's been a disaster
but the amount of money that's going to
cost for Mass deportations are beyond
our capabilities the best thing we can
do is document these people and then
secure the border and you'll end up
getting a bunch of Middle Road people
being like okay fair just like when
Reagan said he wanted he wanted amnesty
and the compromise was we secure the
Border but we Grant amnesty my fear is
let let let let me let me go back a
little back a little bit back in time
this is what I've been saying is going
to happen with Texas I said if Texas is
overwhelmed by this wave of immigration
eventually the state legal apparatus is
going to assert their jurisdiction and
say we're going to do something about
this what did we see state of course
passed the law saying Crossing's illegal
the feds said screw off we saw the feds
trying to remove the bo the barriers and
the water and the razor wire and I said
if the feds keep doing this with Texas
saying no eventually Texas will assert
its jurisdiction and push back on the
feds then Texas did this with armed
soldiers my fear is how this escalates
and so many have made the point that if
Donald Trump moves for Mass deportation
of 15 million people when he gets
elected the left will post photos and
videos of trains and buses in camps and
claim Trump is Hitler now imagine if
it's substantially worse and many of
these people are granted rubber stamped
citizenship by a Joe Biden executive
order
unconstitutionally that doesn't matter
to the Democrat activists and and law
fair activists they will just publicly
say look what is what does okazi Cortez
say all the time legal Ayes refugees
they're lying these are economic
migrants fighting age males who are
coming here by themselves or smuggling
children and then the the media and the
Democrats lie and claim they're refugees
so what happens next year
When Donald Trump is President and the
Democrats just lie and say these are
people who are being naturalized these
are citizens Trump is targeting citizens
and they're going to call it racist he's
saying he's targeting you know Latin
American citizens and they're going to
use their rubber stamp unconstitutional
garbage to try and justify in the Press
yeah I think I mean I think the Optics
would be really bad either way and
that's sort of something I hope
Republicans are thinking about going
into the end of 2024 early 2025 I mean
you asked me when the show started to
look up if how uh Mayor Johnson of
Chicago is doing and the first thing
when I looked up his remarks are uh he's
arguing that Governor abot is
intentionally attacking leaders of color
by busting migrants to the cities I mean
it is going to be an ugly and divisive
fight between these two sides the post
millennial did report it that uh
allegedly there's a reporter who made
the claim Mayor Johnson has suffered
multiple panic attacks at around you
know as immigration is bubbling up and
that's the insinuation for the record on
dacca uh it didn't give anyone
citizenship it it give 2 years stay on
deportation for children that didn't
have uh like felonies or whatever and
then what happened um then they tried to
propose the DREAM Act which would have
given citizenship but that did not pass
it would be highly irregular for um a
dictator to decide who is and is not a
citizen of the country without legal
recourse and there's a lot of things
that Joe Biden has done which would be
highly irregular and dictatorial I do
love the the meme of they've arrested
their political Rivals they're trying to
put the lead candidate uh opposing the
regime into prison all while screaming
the other side are fascists yeah the
people who are trying to censor en
cancer people the people who are who are
conducting you 178,000 illegal
surveillances on American citizens uh
without warrants uh the what the folks
who trying to lock up Donald Trump
they're they say we're the danger to
democracy really let's uh let's jump to
the uh the political world you know uh
we did have some other news but I want
to get into the politics because we have
this this is big news
and it tells you a lot that we do not
lead with this story Ronda Santa
suspends his presidential bid and
endorses Trump this happened yesterday
afternoon uh Ronda gave a speech where
he accidentally quoted Budweiser
thinking he was quoting Winston
Churchill which I see as a perfect U uh
example a perfect uh well how do I say
this it explains his campaign yeah it
encapsulates the whole thing yeah
Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
counts Winston Churchill No in fact that
was a bud Budweiser ad from 1938 talking
about fishermen particularly young men
who don't care if the weather is bad
they will try anyway and uh Well Ron
sure when we played the video in the car
we were driving back home someone
actually asked if it was AI yeah I
thought so too you thought it was AI he
so good he was
smiling relieved the best I've seen him
look in months he looked like wow so
Happ I'm so I'm so glad that this is
over he opens with I'm in Florida and
he's like happy about it he looks like
he's about to cry like hitting yourself
in the head with a hammer it hurts so
much when you stop uh look uh he always
lacked a rationale for his candidacy
what was the rationale for his candidacy
if you wanted the America First
candidate we already had that person uh
that was Donald Trump if you have a
choice of seeing the Beatles or seeing a
Beatles tribute ban which one are you
going to see you're going to go see the
Beatles right so he never had a
rationale for his candidacy
other than saying well something might
happen to Trump but that something
hasn't happened or to the extent that it
has happened it's actually turbocharged
his campaign so he had one foot in the
America First Camp one foot in the
Republican establishment camp but he
could never make a case why him other
than well Trump might be going to jail
that's why he should be me and that
Trump is beloved he is a he's unlike any
political figure we've seen in the in
the history of the country let me let me
play a short little snippet from this uh
dis STIs speech their first Snowman in
New Hampshire they are one of the
reasons we fight so hard for what we
believe in Winston Churchill once
remarked that Success is Not final
failure is not fatal it is the courage
to continue that counts while this
campaign has ended the mission continues
down here in Florida we will continue to
show the country how to lead thank you
and God bless so that was the end of of
course where he quoted Budweiser
thinking it was Winston Churchill but uh
I agree he seems happier than I've seen
him in a long time uh I also I got to be
honest when I saw this I thought it was
AI I thought I thought it was a deep
fake AI generated speech and some people
point out that he flubs a word halfway
through the speech and I'm like that's
actually to me more indicative of it
being AI of it being like autogenerated
all you have to do to make this these
days it's really easy is Ron could stand
up say three sentences he could walk up
and just go how now brown cow the quick
brown fox jumps over the lazy dog leave
and then they can make him say anything
they want I am not actually suggesting
that's what they did it's just I mean
you thought the same thing it was he
talks like this and then he'll go on to
say another sentence and then he'll
continue like this it felt very
robotic I think was that not the problem
of his entire keny
likability is a crucial factor in
politics uh and running for governor is
not the same as running for president
running for governor you can keep the
media at Bay you have to give that many
interviews you can control access to
yourself much tougher to do that when
you're running for president uh and in
this particular case this guy spent
$300
million uh and he dropped out of New
Hampshire because he had dropped below
5% of the vote and that was after
squeezing out a very narrow but dist
second place finish uh in Iowa and he
has long-term problems now in in Florida
where he's hurt his standing very badly
but what the hell's Nikki Haley doing
she's hanging on to try to be vice
president is what she's doing well I I
couldn't agree more but she is the
epitome of the Bush Cheney uh when's the
next foreign war wing of the Republican
party uh and uh they I think would try
to like try to force her on the ticket
uh I think she's going to get beat
tomorrow in New Hampshire by I don't
know 18 19 20 points uh and then we head
to her head her home state where I think
she's going to get shellacked it's not
incidental that the governor of South
Carolina Henry McMaster very good guy
the lieutenant governor most members of
his cabinet most of the leaders both all
the leaders of their legislature were
all in New Hampshire yesterday and today
campaigning against Nikki Haley V did it
right V campaigned for the most part
praising Donald Trump's record and he
actually did not give a good reason for
the longest time as to why he was even
running he ran he said we're going to do
these things and I was like these are
good things he defended Donald Trump
when bad things happened and then only
towards the end he said I'm running
because I think the Deep state will stop
at nothing to remove Donald Trump and if
that's the case the last thing we want
is Nikki Haley to be the only one on the
ticket and I said that's actually a
really good point I'll accept that but
that but I'll tell you this I'm voting
for Donald Trump
and only in that scenario does that make
sense and then when he loses Iowa he
drops out Praises Donald Trump endorses
Donald Trump and campaigns for him and
I'm like that's how you get out of this
he made a name for himself from 0 to 8%
wonderful job and now he's launched a
budding career Ronda santis went from
The Shining Star of Maga to the Oscar
the Grouch living in a trash can and it
is a remarkable feat to be honest well
it's because it denies his origin look
Ronda santis was a completely unknown
obscure Congressman with a bad haircut
and a bad suit who was struggling in
single digits in a race for governor he
was lifted out of political obscurity by
Donald Trump uh 62 Republican County
chairman the entire Republican state
apparatus every elected Republican the
Florida legislature every member of the
Congressional Delegation is a republican
except for Matt Gates had endorsed Adam
putam so Ronda Sanz owed his his
nomination to Donald Trump and then
Trump changed his schedule in the last 3
weeks of the 2018 campaign to return to
Florida three times and literally drag
him over the Finish Line wow uh I didn't
think that voters cared about this you
know what I was wrong voters do care
about this they care about loyalty they
care about gratitude Ron was 42 years
old he couldn't have waited now I think
the flaws in his candidacy would have
shown up in 2028 anyway but he he's not
a viable candidate for 2028 now he could
have tried to play it more like VI did
which would have required him to one not
attack Donald Trump in these ridiculous
ways and then he actually would have had
to have bowed out it would have been a
weird campaign from the get-go
considering how long he would people
were considering him he was the favorite
in the betting odds in January of 2023
yeah leading in the polls he was leading
in the polls talk about throwing that
all in the garbage and for what but but
I do want to
stress it was it was uh people like me
and many others
we we we were like we like Ron but his
campaign is being run by children and
whenever we would say something like
guys you need to fix this what will be
the response of his campaign and I'm not
talking about his fans I'm talking about
quite literally his staff to attack
potential allies and insult them it was
it was unusual I mean I think and and
maybe you have a better insight into
this but so much of the disantis
campaign to me seemed like it was that
pressure that we heard I kept hearing
this over and over again well he has to
run now because if he if he waits uh you
have to strike while the iron is hot if
he waits it'll his uh name will lose
momentum and it'll fall off and he can
never have any big opportunities which
seemed counterintuitive me
counterintuitive to me given that Trump
had really boosted his career if he had
been loyal which is what you hear over
and over again when Trump supporters are
interviewed by the New York Times by
anyone else they say I've been voting
for Trump for this long and I know that
he can do good things and I want to
stick with him they value loyalty and it
seems like that pressure to move uh his
political career forward went against
this this obvious call to loyalty well
he first of all he's got two more years
as Governor which he could have
distinguished himself if he had gone out
and campaigned hard for Donald Trump he
would he he could have earned his
support he could have been next in line
now he's got a gigantic problem we have
a term limitation of two
years there's a senate seat up in 2028
but how does he raise the money what
fulcrum does he have to raise the money
he's going to have a recalcitrant
legislature now because they resent the
fact that he's been missing we have an
insurance uh crisis we have a utility
rate crisis we have a venol crisis
where's Ron Ron's knowwhere to be found
you know what this is this is Donald
Trump is a is a the lead singer in a
rock band charting every every every
week with a new single he finds this guy
to play bass the bass player is standing
on stage thinking like man they love me
I should start my own band so he quits
to start his own band and everyone's
like what ever happened to that guy
that's where he's headed
wild it's weird he he struck while the
iron was
warm he miscalculated the temperature
here I mean that's sad look I it's no
secret that I've been a Critic of his
wife I think she drove this decision I
think she was tremendously ambitious and
she misread the moment it was not his
time he had plenty of time so can he
recover from this like does he have a a
place moving forward in the America
first magga movement or be it's could be
very much up to him but I mean look he
had a super majority in legislature
let's recognize he paid a million dollar
essentially a bribe to the speaker of
the house it's a legal bribe because he
gives a million dollars to his political
action committee and they change the
state law so that only one person who
holds State office can run for federal
office without giving up their state
office so if I was in the state house
and I want to run for Congress I have to
resign but not Ronda santis he can run
for president while remaining uh
governor of Florida changing the law
just for him him was a bad idea to begin
oh yeah he went to Iowa during a state
of emergency in Florida that was that
was the last nail in the coffin for me I
I had been defending like look well we
know he's good on policy he did well in
Florida but his campaign's bad and then
I found out he's in Iowa it was a
blizzard we we were were you in Iowa by
by chance no I was not but but I
remember it well we were we were in Iowa
minus you know 15 degrees or whatever
stores are all closed heavy snow and
Ron's like I should be here instead of
my home state which is under aate
emergency that he declared he flies in
declares flies out I was like wow that's
their election of Duty I thought it was
weird when he went to Japan and was
pretending that he wasn't about to
campaign you know like there were lots
of things that sort of felt disingenuous
and I'm not here to be I mean I'm not a
huge there are there were some things
about his campaign like some of his
immigration stuff that I thought was
interesting ultimately he never was who
I was going to vote for um but I think
what's worse is that we're sort of uh
stealing our future I I think ultimately
four more years of trump and then who
comes after that there has to be a
Legacy of people to fill these seats
when people are term Li limited and
can't move on let's talk about New
Hampshire tomorrow I think one of the
more interesting stories here is that
Joe Biden will not be on the ballot in
New Hampshire which is strange and their
are activists staging a right in
campaign for Joe Biden which surprised
me I was watching Fox news earlier and
they interviewed a woman who was holding
up a sign saying right in Joe Biden I
was like I've never seen a Joe Biden
supporter before I guess there are some
when they have to right in they appear
yeah I mean I guess that happens but you
know while many people are talking about
what's going on with the Republican
primaries how it's basically a big waste
of time Trump's going to win and they're
trying to keep Trump's name off the
ballots in these states Democrats have
just basically shut down their primary
not allowing anyone to challenge Joe
Biden so why is he not on the ballot and
and what's the strategy here uh they
changed their rules uh so they stripped
Iowa the first in the nation caucuses of
their Del delegates to try to discourage
them from having caucuses they didn't
have them the New Hampshire primary is
mandated by New Hampshire state law not
the Democratic National Committee rules
so to punish them for having uh the
primary anyway uh they both strip them
of their delegates within the convention
and Biden doesn't put his name on the
ballot now New Hampshire is a state
where writing in a name is really very
simple DWI Eisenhower won the Republican
primary there for he wasn't even on the
ballot he won his a right in in 1952
Henry Kat Lodge won the nomination or
the primary there 1964 in a right it's
very simple to do uh now they're they
fear being embarrassed by this little
known congressman who did file for the
primary Dean Phillips who I don't know
much about so now they are hustling to
get out a vote for Joe Biden well
there's Maran Williamson as well and
Marian Williamson I don't believe Jen
yuger is on the ballot in New Hampshire
either uh I I'm not following that I
know that he's gotten on in some states
but of course he was not born in the
United States or two American parents so
uh there's Supreme Court ruling
basically I mean there's a constitution
saying you have to be a natural born
citizen but there was also a ruling uh
already rejecting his argument as to why
after being you know Jen yuger is
arguing that he is a a citizen in full
rights as same as anybody else so he
should be allowed to run there there's
an interesting argument to be made there
but I don't know if he's G going to
appear on the ballot but I would say
that if even with this R in campaign I
think it's possible that Marian
Williamson wins this one maybe I mean
the the big tension for me is that now
the DNC has really isolated the New
Hampshire uh branch of the democratic
party theyve they sent them there the um
assistant um the Assistant Attorney
General sent this letter to them I think
it was like two weeks ago it was a cease
and deist letter saying you cannot in
writing which they did the the rules
committee for the DNC sent a letter to
the New Hampshire Democratic party
saying uh if you hold anything on during
the primary it's meaningless and you
should not encourage voters to do
anything and this is discouraging people
from voting this is uh voter
interference voter suppression and it's
really building tension between this
party and this National Mega group that
says you guys have to comply with what
we want even if it's against your state
laws I would say it's anti-democracy
wouldn't you I would too I mean it's
actual voter suppression to say it's
it's meaningless right that's crazy well
look the Democratic National uh
selection process was pre-wired their
first real contest is South Carolina
where you have an absolute majority of
African-American primary voters uh I I
have predicted for sometime Joe has had
the the the way cleared for him to win
enough delegates to be nominated but
that would not stop him just before the
Democratic Nation convention which just
happens to be in Chicago to announce
that he's decided not to run for reasons
of Health throw the convention open uh
to uh uh to the selection of another
candidate Michelle Obama will say oh I'm
not interested I don't want it I don't
want it no thank you I don't want to do
it okay I'll do it but what'll happen is
she'll say oh no no no I I couldn't do
it and then you'll start hearing chants
of Michelle
Michelle and she'll smile and then Brock
will come out and he'll say I think this
nation needs a leader and I'm going to
ask you right now here on stage to take
this responsibility for this country and
answer the call and she's going to wipe
away a tear and say I'll do it
and they're gonna
go Fain becoming like the biggest beta
male on Earth he'll be like I am the
first
man I am the first man I look I've been
predicting this openly for two years I
see Bill O'Reilly had a column today I
still think she will be the nominee of
the Democratic Party by the way I think
she'll be a very strong formidable
candidate people who make jokes about it
or making a gigantic mistake like a year
ago that's why I pegged too I mean she's
got the biggest star name she's got the
Obama name Superstar her non-political
not viewed as political one of the most
admired women in the country uh I I
still think she will be their strongest
possible candidate so we we we had we've
had a bunch of uh potential partic uh we
we've had a bunch of predictions as to
what we think may happen one prediction
is that Nikki Haley is is in the bag for
Democrats he's getting Democrat votes
and and uh supporters and voters she's
getting voters and donors and the idea
one of the ideas that V brought up I
thought was good is why actually try and
win a contest in in November when all
you have to do is try and supplant Trump
in the primary with someone like Nikki
Haley who is an establishment favorite
as well now I don't know if How likely
that's going to be it looks like she's
going to get you just wiped out and then
she doesn't have any any opportunity to
move forward especially with the Sanda
and vake now being out of the race it's
just her she's not going anywhere but
then you have the potential of or the
question that we've brought up I've been
saying this for some time that Biden
will not be the nominee I think he is
going to drop out I think it's going to
be health reasons a JP Morgan strategist
believes that come March around super
Tuesday Biden will announce he's
dropping out this opens the door so so
uh many people countered saying no they
can't Tim it's too late for a primary
you and and and the response is that's
perfect it allows them to avoid a Bernie
Sanders situation or a Marian Williamson
or RFK situation it allows them to stop
any of these candidates from Gaining
traction and gaining delegates so that
when they as you describe
Biden drops out they can just at an open
convention super delegate Michelle Obama
or Gavin Newsome yeah they can control
they can control uh they can control the
convention that way but uh Michelle
pardon me Camala Harris is a problem for
them because any in any normal scenario
she'd be next in line she's a sitting
vice president uh but they also fear she
can't win an election either that would
be correct uh and within and within the
uh the construct of their party she
represents a very important constituency
she's a woman of color so how do you
justify bypassing her I think the answer
is Barack Obama persuades her that when
the first supreme court nomination
becomes available if they win the
presidency in control of the Senate
she's a former Attorney General of
California she gets that job she
graciously steps aside uh and we have a
ticket that is comprised of Michelle
Obama for president and Gavin Nome for
vice president and Gavin can raise
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
special interest dollars for that ticket
that's a good back room explanation KLA
Harris will be offered a supreme court
seat but they're not going to publicly
say that no she I think it's actually
really really simple a lot of people
said how do you get past Kamala Harris
it's really simple Joe Biden announces
he's stepping down or he's suffering a
health issue kamla Harris I think there
there there could be an instance where
Joe Biden actually says I can no longer
perform my duties I need Kamala to serve
as acting president kamla simply says
I will not try to seek a presidency when
I'm filling this role it would be it
would be irresponsible or or uh you know
it would be wrong to try and win an
election this this late in the game I'll
just do my duties and then bow out
here's why I don't think that happens I
think Joe needs to maintain the legal
authority to Pardon his son and his
brother and himself and the other
members of the Biden crime family uh
he's wanted this he's wanted this job
his entire life uh I don't think Dr
Jill's anxious to go by any means uh so
I think I once thought I once agreed
with you I thought that he left early I
don't think he leaves early I think he
fills out the term but just doesn't run
I mean they're all one big happy family
tree son you know what I mean committing
treason so uh I'm I'm half kidding why
wouldn't he just along with his cronies
go to Kamala and say uh look pardon
Hunter me and anybody else I'll bow out
2 months 3 months four months or
whatever it's all yours because it would
eradicate her political career she gets
to be the first female president well if
she pardoned all those people it' be
like a taint on her life for the next 30
or 40 years bid The Fall Guys he not be
it did cost Gerald Ford
re-election a very narrow Race by
pardoning Nixon had he not pardon Nixon
I think he would have won he lost by a
hair he lost a very close race and that
was two years after Watergate I mean
think about it come on they go to kamla
and say how would you like to be the
first female president in history your
name will never be forgotten all you got
to do
pardon the Biden crime family you're not
going to run for re-election we'll then
move you to a supreme court seat or
something like this but you will be in
the history books forever she says deal
who would not want their name to be on
that plaque do you risk voters who are
wanting the new Democratic uh nominee to
be a woman of color like splitting the
votes at any deleg at any convention
between her and Michelle Obama if you do
that I suppose there is the argument
that Michelle Obama is the is the
nominee they could they would be said
saying this could be the first woman of
color to ever be president you have to
vote for her and then try and go for the
woke angle that's that's and you've
already done it with Cala so it's you
right so you burn that one out but you
know it's it's perhaps that it I I I I
how do you publicly get past kamla
Harris they've really created an
obstacle for themselves which is sort of
hilarious because I think when they
started they really thought maybe she
can be the AA parent maybe it'll be fine
which is crazy I I don't think they
thought that I think they were like we
can't have sty old white man with all
these progressives you need a woman of
color in there somewhere yeah I think
she doesn't even know why she's there
actually think Biden accidentally
painted himself in a corner I don't
think it was in the plan he blurred it
out I'm gonna have a vice president
who's going to be a woman of color he
just he just said it is that illegal
violation of the 1964 Civil Rights Act
One of these things that overturned
affirmative action at that point so you
know what it's been driving me a little
sideways regarding the Supreme Court you
mentioned that the Obamas might go to
KLA Harris and be like well we would
consider you for the Supreme Court or
that they would just put her in the
Supreme Court like do we have nine
people making decisions for the entire
state of Texas that's like I appreciate
what it what it's done and how it stands
and how it questions the legislature and
how it can overturn presidential
Authority and stuff but giving this kind
of mass authority to nine people that
are appointed they're not even voted
into office they're appointed by some
political Zealot some president and then
confirmed like that's so much power for
such a small group of people I don't
know it's great I love it I think it's
beautiful it's the it's one of the
brilliant things in the US
constition as long as the court is
indeed not politicized and then when
when a politicized person gets appointed
they're they're there for life like
there's that that should be overturn
like there should be ter or something
one of the smartest political creations
of mankind is the American form of
government and we take it for granted
because we grew up in it but when the
founding fathers were trying to put
together this system they really did
make the best that has been so far can
it be better always there there are ways
to improve that's why the Constitution
can be amended so uh are there faults
can we improve we always can we always
should look for ways to do so but at the
time the American system of government
is a masterpiece and to this day still
stands as the best form of government in
the world and when the Supreme Court
ruled against some some aspects of the
New Deal Franklin Roosevelt tried
exactly that to expand the court to pack
the court it did not go over well and he
failed what did he do uh he put forward
a proposal to expand the court and it
was defeated in the Senate
so n there were nine then there's nine
nine there's nine then there's nine now
he wanted more the argument is that uh
what what do we have 12 districts how
many think that's right pellet districts
or whatever that there should be a judge
for each um region I I it's been so long
since I've we've covered this stuff
heavily but the the reason why it's
brilliant is if you if you break it down
to the most rudimentary of forms you
have a group of people who just declared
independence you had the Articles of
Confederation you did not have a
Constitution you had a very weak
government and they're trying to figure
out like what how how do we run this
thing and then someone says we should
have a King George Washington he should
be king and they're like no no no we
can't have a king because then George
may be great but what about his kids and
then his corruption okay well what about
like a direct democracy what if people
just voted no because then people vote
for stupid things and you need some
expertise in there okay what about like
a Council of Elders appointed
individuals who are of of great standing
within their communities and so you have
a how about all three how about we have
a Council of Elders a direct democ a
representative democracy or with I
should say a represent constitutional
rep representative Republic and a strong
executive we do all three and we make
them fight each other checks and
balances how about we don't just choose
one of these governments we've seen
before we do all of them yeah but if
we're actually talking about making
kamla Harris on our Council of Elders
like what what have we done to our
national wisdom no she's not someone I
would think of as like an elder wise man
this is the beauty of the system she
would be I for appointment is subject to
confirmation of the US Senate like any
other Citizen and and a a a truly good
system doesn't just always have god tier
perfect people running the show the the
the idea that one Supreme Court Justice
is bad I think shows that there is
flexibility within the system if we had
a single Monarch sure you have problems
you're talking about katangi Brown
Jackson how old is she CU you're talking
about Council of Elders like what's her
age is she really wise is a figure of
speech I'm saying it's not supposed to
be though it really is supposed to be
the wisest Among Us that sit on the
Supreme Court for life and people are
chosen and then confirmed by the Senate
and the problem here is the 17th
amendment should be uh uh what are your
thoughts on the 17th I think we should
get rid of it I'm not I think it was Ben
sass who first proposed not not first
but what is the s that the Senate is
chosen by popular vote in the states as
opposed to the state representatives
used to be done by the state legislator
the state legislator would choose you
Senators uh and then they changed it so
they were done by direct election of the
and that's a mistake and this is what
causes part of the problem when you have
people voting locally for their state
reps those reps know about your local
issues your sitting member of Congress
knows a little bit but they're going to
DC and they're voting on war and Omnibus
spending bills or whatever so if you go
and vote for a state senator or a state
rep and you say to them you know old uh
Crossland Creek over there is full of
garbage we need someone to get the job
done they go yeah I've seen it cuz I
live not too far away local
representation then all of these people
go to their session and say who are we
going to send to the federal government
to represent our state and they will
choose who they think the best person is
this creates state representation as
opposed to National Democrat
representation so the problem now is the
Democratic party says we want Democrats
we need Statewide voting and and it's
all about some federal policy as opposed
to what's going on in your state which
results in Senators who will confirm
anybody so long as they're Partyline
shills then you end up with a uh katangi
Brown who says I don't know what a woman
is it's like oh wow so that's a problem
I agree and sure we should repeal the
17th I think with the internet I I I
disagree I I like the direct election of
senators otherwise you all you get or
career politicians there never would
ever be an opening for anyone else so
the politicians basically choose the US
senators there's a time in New Jersey
when two brothers were US senators at
the same time why they were chosen by
the New Jersey state legislature back in
the 20s yeah I I I get that uh I
disagree it I think I think if if people
people no one no one pays attention at
all to state representation anymore and
so now you get these ads which are
remarkable to me where it is a person
running for a federal house seat in
Congress saying if you vote for me I'm
going to fix our district and clean
things up no you're not you're going to
go to DC and represent the district to
to the federal government you're going
to vote on whether or not we bomb a
country or how taxes are at the federal
level you're not going to vote at all on
how we deal with garbage in our city
that's a local rep a mayor a councilman
who does that people don't care anymore
we could do like an addendum to the 17th
Amendment where like state governments
will select their Senators but then the
the citizens have to confirm them to the
Senate via a vote and if they deny that
then maybe the citizens could vote for
their own yeah what about what about the
state reps will select and it has to be
confirmed by popular vote and then if
it's overturned then the populace can
vote for someone they want it's
overturned the state legislature has to
go back and renominate and then approve
another somebody else I mean that's a
step I like that like no names like you
saying can come out of the S Side Lane
and be like yo the people love me and
I'm the best for the job even though the
people at the state government don't
know who I am and that person might get
a shot at the Senate I like that too but
I I I don't you know I just don't think
you'll ever get You' never get any
Outsiders elected you'd always get
people who are part of the system
because if the state could just keep
nominating insiders over and over and
you have to keep saying no no no no at
some point the population's got to be
able to put their own person there's
always a family that's involved in state
politics or several of them in every
state I mean there's sort of a a control
right let's uh let's jump to some
cultural news we have this story from
cnr.com
Dana White explains free speech to
reporter quote free speech Brother
people can say whatever they want and
they can believe whatever they want so
following the fight with uh sha
Strickland and dricus
dupi sha uh uh Shawn had made several
statements in the past about trans
people and you know uh people who have
who have gay kids and things like that
he mostly called a reporter a weak man
who was the enemy he said that he was
there to stand up for the people of of
Canada F trau during the fight people
were chanting F trau Joe Rogan said
Canada get your is together man but I
love I love the UFC fan base I love the
fighters we saw Donald Trump come out at
a UFC event Madison Square Garden with
Kid Rock and Tucker Carlson the whole
crowd of in New York City screaming and
cheering for these individuals it's
beautiful and so I'm seeing this stuff
and I'm thinking you know I've never
been super big on UFC stuff but with
these guys willing to stand up for what
they believe in for the fans willing to
stand up for what they believe in I'm
getting excited for this so Dana White
comes out and they ask him this uh
reporter says you obviously give a Long
Leash to your Fighters about what they
can say when they are up there with the
UFC microphone Dana leash snaps back
saying I don't give a leash to anybody
they can say whatever they want now this
is a sport I like yeah I love that
that's fantastic and then you get Shan
Strickland who was the champ I said it
was I think he still is and you have
this split decision after the fight
where they claim he lost the title and
so this is uh generating quite a bit of
controversy there's a lot of people
saying grow up stop being a whiny little
he lost but I I I I I I'll just
put it this way and then we can talk
about it there's a conspiracy theory of
course people are going to suggest this
that the reason Strickland was uh lost
was not because he was the worst fighter
but because he's causing problems for
the brand so when people say to Dana
White you give your Fighters a Long
Leash and then he says I don't give
anybody a leash Dana White actually said
publicly he thought Strickland won the
fight but there are people saying on
Twitter and I don't blame him they're
saying that when budlight comes and
sponsors UFC and one of the Champs
starts ragging on Bud Light and putting
serious pressure on them there's going
to be pressure to get him out if they
can to end the quote unquote era of
Strickland I don't know that I believe
that all I can say is this I'm not a big
UFC guy I don't know or care about
points and scoring I I I get it exists
all I can say is I get really excited
when you know we've had Colby Covington
here in the studio it was awesome to
meet this guy someone willing to stand
up for Trump publicly with no fear
because these Fighters have balls and
for Shan Strickland to defend the people
of Canada wearing a make Canada great
again shirt I I tremendously love and
respect the defense of the working
people by people in these positions who
can speak up and have have influence so
I say wow I got to watch this I want I
want to see this guy fight he's the
champ I watch a fight I watch a guy win
a fight I watch them claim the other guy
won the fight I don't get it I mean I
understand why they're claiming he lost
I think it's the stupidest thing ever
and it makes me feel like it's all
fake I don't know I didn't see the fight
you said he got knocked down five times
no Strickland there were six takedowns
but uh I I'll put it this way if if if I
see two guys fighting in the street it's
like the average person looks at that
and says like oh man that guy's beating
that guy up that's basically what
happened here Strickland was beating the
other guy up and then in the end they
were like yeah well you know he got
knocked down a handful of times and so
the judges thought it went the other way
so we're ging him that the they guy the
fight so the Supreme Court of MMA has
ruled I gotta tell you I went to the UFC
fight with Donald Trump in Las Vegas uh
several months ago it was an
extraordinary experience first of all
never had there been this much
testosterone in one Hall any place in
the country I mean it was it was an all
American Extravaganza nobody was nobody
was snacking on tofu if you know what I
mean and the the reaction that Trump got
was extraordinary just extraordinary now
I'm a big fan of Co of Kobe Covington
I'm still I still haven't gotten over
the fact that he lost but you know what
he'll be back his greatest Victory is Li
ahead that guy's got guts uh and I'm
absolutely convinced that he comes back
I completely agree uh that was another
one of these fights so with with
Colby I was thinking he may actually
have taken in the last round but again
like I don't know I'm like for me I
watched that fight and I'm like honestly
I have no idea in the end he like the
final round Colby absolutely you know I
think he won that final round and then
he said he thought he won the fight too
watching the Strickland fight I just
that guy want to fight I feel like this
is the kind of thing that Strickland
will just be like and now I'm more
motivated than ever to do anything I can
to to be victorious I mean I've only
heard him interviewed a couple times I
haven't watched UFC consistently in
years but uh he's a really tenacious
person and he is very uh he's a very
strong sense of self and I think that
really drives his desire to compete and
I think that's actually why so many
people like him like yes his takes are
kind of interesting and not what you
expect but more than anything he is a
person of intense conviction but as for
uh I really like and Trust Dana White so
I there's no way in the world he would
wire a fight I I never I never
understood their you know their scoring
system I saw the same fight you did I
thought Strickland won but what do I
know I'm not one of the judges look at
this all that matters is uh uh Joe Rogan
he apparently agrees so I defer to him
and if Dana White also the story from
MMA junkie Joe Rogan surprised judges
awarded dricus dupi win over sha
Strickland it's an amazing clip I
watched it Rogan normally is
commentating on these fights and uh when
the when the ruling came down he says
wow
interesting very interesting I wonder
how the people online feel about that
cuz we're not scoring it while we're
watching it we're just having fun were
we wrong that's exactly how I felt when
I watched this I I I'm like dude I
bought this pay-per-view thing I'm super
excited to support Sean Strickland he's
he's he's standing up for the little guy
it's exactly what we want to see in
these Sports I watch a fight I watched
this guy win it was close dupi is
amazing it was a really awesome fight uh
Strickland his eyes covered in blood it
was it was good and then they're just
like nah he loses and I'm like what man
so I don't know dude I'm just I don't
understand it I guess we have this uh
from verdict mma.com a lot of people
were sending me where you've got a
couple different metrics by which the
fight was judged and scored and it looks
like the media like like media uh uh
scored it for for Strickland but the
judges went the other direction on it so
it is what it is man I don't think it
was a I I don't believe that it was
rigged in the sense that like Dana White
had anything to do with it Dana White
publicly stated he thought Strickland
won too yeah that indicates there's
going to be a
rematch GNA create some uh between the
two fighters the box office on that yes
so I say I say Shenanigans it sucks
whatever he got robbed people are like
he didn't get robbed he just lost I'm
like dud that's what it means like it
was a close fight we get that they gave
to the other guy he was robbed meaning
it should have slightly gone the other
direction but a rematch could be really
good in that everything Strickland got
to say will be Amplified tenfold when we
start building up to a potential rematch
which I really hope happens yeah I was
thinking about the uh bread and circus
they say in failing Empires they the
Empire gives its citizens bread and
circus in order to keep them distracted
and fed so they don't Riot and then they
just and so this is the circus aspect
but the difference is that we've got
mass media and internet video like Sean
Strickland can make a video and like
alter the minds of the masses in a day
that I the Romans didn't have the
Gladiators didn't have that kind of
influence on society or their own
Instagram Pages where they can post
Clips or them working out or doing I
mean like people become really devoted
to a lot of athletes but definitely UFC
athletes who are just like they
personify something they aspire to be
right they're tough they're strong
they're con they're like Peak physical
fitness and this is a day and age where
you can feel like a personal
relationship to these athletes in a way
that you never have before it's crazy
when we had Colby Covington on I had a
lot of people being like Oh man cuz he's
such a wild guy and then he shows up and
he's the nicest most polite honorable
guy and you people need to understand
that right that he he's out there he's
he's he's being a personality but he's
he's a good regular dude he knows what
he's doing he's a smart guy he's he's
he's I'm a big fan and it was really
awesome to get to meet him but I
appreciate when you know I see all the
time let me put it this way why I like
UFC so much I've been skateboarding my
whole life I was skateboarding earlier
today tried to do a kick flip pivot
slipped out it was fun didn't land it
all these pro skateboarders will hit me
up being like I'm a big fan of your show
man but I can't say anything because
I'll I'll get fired or whatever I'm so
scared and I'm like man it's like these
guys who jump off buildings for a living
their balls dropped off and then I see
Kobe Covington and Strickland and I'm
like these guys will shut to the High
Heavens F you I'll say whatever I feel
like saying now that inspires me and I'm
like these guys are great so I like what
UFC is doing as you mentioned more
testosterone what did you say it's the
most testosterone I've ever seen in one
place at one time I'm looking forward to
seeing more of these guys yeah but
cultural victories I guess right the
fact that uh Trump can walk out in a
urban Democrat stronghold and have the
whole crowd cheering for him this is you
know it was pandemonium it wasn't just
cheering the play he turned the place
upside down it was absolute earsplitting
pandemonium that's awesome I think he's
the most famous guy on Earth right now
he is yeah well and people I mean look
I've known him a long time I'm not
allowed to say how old because he says
it makes us both sound old but the guy's
energy level is just extraordinary I
mean he he's he's always required very
little sleep but through all of this and
I talked to him Sunday he's
upbeat he he's Resolute he's determined
he's extraordinarily confident
uh he's in a great mood uh and he's
surviving on not much sleep cuz remember
he wins the Iowa caucuses then he has to
fly landing in New York City at 3:30 in
the morning appear in court the next day
through the afternoon then fly back to
New Hampshire do a rally then fly back
to New York to appear in court in the
morning I mean he's 77 years old but
he's he he's got the stamina of a 26y
old were you friends way back like what
were you guys friends in business or
were you just friends uh I I met him in
1979 when I recruited he and his father
for the finance chairman for to be
members of the finance committee for
Ronald Reagan's campaign for president
of the United States in New York state
that's how we met and they both joined
Regan's fin they both raise substantial
money for it was that Don's first uh
like foray into politics uh you know if
you're in New York City developer you're
always in politics and you and you cover
both sides remember the city's dominated
by democrats and Democrats control stuff
like permitting and Zoning so Donald was
was was friendly with all politicians of
both parties uh it was uh the the first
person in the country really to suggest
that Trump should run for president was
Richard Nixon Nixon's in Exile he is a
friend of George Stein brener who owns
the New York Yankees uh he and Trump
meet in Stein Brenner's box Nixon knows
I had done some work for Trump Trump
knows I'm close to Nixon Nixon calls me
the next day well I met your man say Sir
this guy could go all the way I'm saying
you're saying he should run for govern
no no no I said all the way and then
there's a famous letter which Nixon and
hand writes to Trump telling him he
should run for president the New York
Times is what year was it this had to be
80s around 89 well there's that uh8 it
like he was on Oprah or something and he
asked if he was going to run for
president yes he and you know says
probably not probably not unless things
got so bad that I had no choice yeah and
we came to that point I didn't know we
were at that point in 2012 I just
thought stuff was a little crazy but I
didn't realize like that the liberal
economic order was morphing into this
new world order that it had been planned
for 30 or 40 years and I had no idea
well in retrospect we still weren't
quite at that moment so in 2012 he I
think reluctantly endorsed m Romney he
almost immediately had sellers re
remorse every time there's a debate he
would call me and say what's wrong with
this guy he's got no Instinct for the
jugular and then it was New Year's day
of
2013 when he said I've applied to the to
the patent and trademark office to
trademark the phrase make America great
again what year was that 2013 yeah so he
he I knew he was running in 2016 uh
Michael Moore tried claiming that Trump
didn't actually want to run it was did
you see that documentary he did
Fahrenheit 119 and he's saying something
was it Gwen Stefani or something like
this like someone got a bigger NBC
contract than Trump and Trump was
offended because he's the he's the big
shot he's The Apprentice so he decided
he would run for president just to
bolster his uh his his recognition and
then try and get a better contract but
then he accidentally won it's the most
insane thing Michael Moore what were you
thinking the dude say he trademarked
Maga right years in Advance everybody
knew this was coming but look he talked
about running uh in
2000 he he talk he talked about running
in 1988 first time he went to Portsmith
New Hampshire where he was two nights
ago to speak to the Portsmith Chamber of
Commerce the first time there was
speculation about him running he was
nowhere near ready I don't think he was
that he wasn't that serious about it but
he wanted to kind of test the waters
then he looked at it again in 2000 Jesse
Ventura who had had uh become governor
of Minnesota uh had been obviously a
very famous wrestler urged him to do it
Ross perau his fellow billionaire urged
him to do it uh he still wasn't ready I
think he toyed with it but he he never
ran by the way he won the Reform Party
primaries in Michigan in California
weeks after withdrawing as a candidate
and saying definitively he would not be
a candidate uh he looked at it seriously
again in 2012 the reporters all insisted
he's just burnishing the brand he's
never really going to run this is all
great great PR genius I think he was
always seriously interested he was
waiting for the right time 2016 turned
out to be the right time and isn't that
better I mean if what he said on Oprah
he's thinking about it if he needed to
run then he would I think that's much
more of the like servant leadership that
people don't actually give Trump credit
for it wasn't about his ego it was about
saying I can actually change something I
can make a difference here it's cost him
hundreds of millions of dollars he was
universally he was universally liked now
he's a polarizing figure it's cost him
millions in legal fees he's put up with
an enormous amount of vituperation
attacks on his family he's doing it
because he loves the country he's not
doing it because he needs more Name ID
the Trump the first Trump term was a
magical time despite the cinder blocks
they duct taped to Trump's feet it was
it was a great time I mean e
economically especially and of course
2020 things got wonky but I don't blame
Trump for that and then you have the
years and these past uh uh 3 and a half
years have been miserable it's just been
it's it's been atrophy the 2016 to 20
was like agitation it was like you can
use it you can use agitation to grow
muscle you know you agitate the system
to cause a growth response or you cause
an immune response you cause a lot of
things with agitation but lately it's
just felt like it's falling apart that's
wasting away like there's
no I don't know it's a very hopeless
time especially if you're a young voter
in this country which is why once again
he's exactly the right man at the right
time people who don't know him just have
no idea how tough this guy is he's he's
extraordinarily tough I worked for
Richard Nixon very tough guy greatest
political comeback in American political
history I work for Senator Bob Dole
another tough guy he got hit by a shell
in World War II they told me never walk
again never have the use of I he nursed
himself back to health to a senate
career and to win a presidential
nomination one of the greatest men of
the 20th century those guys were very
very tough guys Trump is tougher than
Nei one of them well you got into
politics to during the Nixon era uh yes
that was my first boss what got you
involved in it well actually I was
originally a Goldwater Zealot when I was
12 years old uh I read the book
conscience of a conservative uh and I
realized that I was an anti-communist
who believed in personal freedom and
small government and a strong National
Defense uh and privacy uh and then when
Goldwater lost I was crushed because I
was 12 years old what the hell do you
know when you're 12 years old uh and
then I I started reading about Nixon and
I concluded that he had been robbed of
the 1960 election so I wrote him a
letter when he was in Exile uh
practicing law on Wall Street and I told
him if he ever ran again I wanted to
sign up uh and they kept my letter on
file for two years and then when he
decided to make a comeback uh I got a
call asked me if I wanted to come in and
interview for a job you were in your 20s
they a little surprised when I was 16
years old yeah at that point you got the
job as a gopher yeah I want I want to
talk about uh this uh story from the
hill we we've talked about it quite a
bit but I do want to bring it up in
another context because we're we're
we're talking right now about what life
was like in the Trump era from we're
talking you know 2017 into the beginning
of 2021 and right now we keep seeing
these stories pop up this one's from
from last from a month ago of course
that Trump is getting a big boost with
younger voters we're now seeing another
story that genz groups are panicking and
trying to buy up domains and that
support Trump to trick Trump supporting
young people into not supporting him
that's how panicked the Democrats are
and I saw this video today of a micro
apartment in New York City it's uh you
know 60 70 square feet it has no
bathroom it has no kitchen it is a sink
and it is a like 5 1/2 foot by 10 foot
Corridor with a
door and I think young people are
starting to understand it when New York
City offers up free housing for illegal
immigrants free healthcare for illegal
immigrants and you a young person
entering the workforce entering
adulthood can't afford an apartment and
can't afford Healthcare you start to
wonder what it is the Democrats are
doing and why they are doing it to you
and when Donald Trump was President
things were a whole lot better the
economy was booming Jim Kramer for all
of his failed predictions said the best
numbers of Our Lives pertaining to
unemployment economic growth Etc now
under Joe Biden it's been miserable
young people are are excited about
living in pods they've got these in San
Francisco you can live in this big room
with like what is it 3x3 pods and you
can climb into your designated tube
which is you know each pod is like four
feet you know uh square like like it'sit
like a twins siiz bed basically not even
are you serious have you seen these
tubes I mean like approximately it's not
fully they cannot fit a twin siiz bed
you think these these pods where you go
into a big room and it's 4 feet tall 4
feet wide and 10 ft deep you can lay
down on an air mattress in that thing if
you're lucky that's how small they are
and they're advertising these are the
Cubbies you can live in you can live in
this is what young people have to look
forward to so it's not surprising to me
that many of them joke all day and night
on social media they have memes about
killing themselves because they're like
haha what's the point of
living I think one of the big reasons
many of us AR to vote for Trump is
because they can see the writing on the
wall they understand Biden is bad he
will make life hard for you Trump is an
open door with light at the end of the
tunnel it's the migrancy crisis man and
this idea that sometimes your leader
needs to be cruel perceivably cruel to
those out there so that you in here can
prosper and like sorry at some point
like there's they're always going to
make more people so there's always going
to be more of them out there and I need
to protect my Society i' I've for for
ages thought differently that we could
protect everybody but the reality is
that's why we build walls these these
young voters are are inside this big
mansion that is the United States they
don't have a bedroom they're not getting
any food and they're asking why is it
that we are here giving our money and
working in this place and what are the
Democrats doing opening the door and
letting strange people come in and eat
all the food young people can see that
and take the jobs that that young people
need I think it's about Economic
Opportunity what's the point of going to
college racking up a debt to do so and
then when you get out of college there
are no jobs available MH but your
student loans you can't go bankrupt on
your student loans and they're issuing
them forever and ever and ever I mean I
think Economic Opportunity is ultimately
going to change young voters uh from
left leaning you know everyone says that
when you're younger Democrat and when
you're old or conservative I was never a
Democrat uh and I think part of it is
the life that people want to leave is
not sustain sustainable under Biden I
mean even if you did want to live in a
city and you know live in the box and do
whatever you know you can't and I think
more and more young people are starting
to see that and saying actually I want
to own land actually I don't want to be
dependent on anyone else actually the
things that I think will will will
sustain me long term line up with a
different uh group of people than are
traditionally pushed on
me yes yeah it's a big cultural shift
that's what I like about the youngest
generation which is like they are this
weird mix of super hopeless people but
then some of them are extremely
motivated to be different we'll see
these waves of young people who are
saying I don't I don't want these things
I want to live differently and I I have
always credited it a lot to um like the
emergence of homeschooling as a dominant
force in America I think that people
being more invested in their education
and challenging sort of status quo
teaching uh has really ignited a a a
powerful energy among these young voters
are coming down the pike um but to a
certain extent they have to be met with
some positive reinforcement and that's
why a trump presidency is so interesting
right now because if you could give them
the chance to have economic Prosperity
they would really cement the culture
they're drifting towards I mean Also
let's just be honest Trump is the more
punk rock candidate that they have to
choose from and even if you're if like
if their attitude really was that they
believe Trump is the
apocalypse but they're making memes all
day and night about burning everything
down and killing themselves then they'd
also be voting for Trump too so it's
just there's nothing Joe Biden has to
offer Donald Trump is the guy who tell
who gives a middle finger to the to the
Press mocks the system and he's got that
youthful exuberance so in terms of
wanting to just screw the system over
it's Trump mm Trump's the
anti-establishment also his I know his
friends a lot of his friends and family
and like people they seem genuinely
interested in in technology I haven't
been pinged by the Biden industry to be
like yo what's the solution here the
solution is graphine and hydrogen we can
alter our fuel system so that we're
using hydrogen fuel in addition to oil
carbon based fuel I'm I'm I'm not having
this increase our GDP by 10 times I'm
not I'm not having this okay you're
supposed to be promoting graphine now
you're switching to hydrogen fuel they
come it's a it's a part and paral
package have you heard of graphine
before yes yeah this shit's dude
this is going to be the 21st century
Building Material we're going to be
pumping this out of Rice
University they figured out how to hit
carbon trash with a laser or it's
actually with electricity they'll take
any carbon they'll run a 7,000 degree
current through it turn it into black
powder he desperately wants you to tell
Trump to embrace graffi that's why he's
saying this it's it's a solution it like
it's a material solution and it'll
alleviate like the the sector of the
copper industry that we relyant on and
the let's let's let's let's bring this
into practical terms steel what are you
are you are you working directly with
the Trump campaign uh not in a formal
capacity but I'm certainly helping
Donald Trump I think he's the peace and
prosperity candidate I me I agree I mean
those are the two your two crucial
issues Beyond immigration we are loping
closer and closer to a World War uh both
in the Russia Ukraine in situation and
in the Middle East Donald Trump could
solve both of those issues relatively
quickly but in in in domestically we've
got the immigration problem and we're
wasting money in Ukraine which affects
us domestically but what do you see
Trump doing in terms of manufacturing
and in terms of uh lower skill labor for
American citizens first all drill baby
drill we got to go back to to the fact
that there's enough Black Gold there's
enough coal there enough Natural Gas
under under our own feet to fuel the
country for a hundred years we're back
to having to beg the Venezuelans or the
Russians or others uh for for fuel this
makes no sense at all every president my
lifetime has promised us energy and
Independence and none of them delivered
Donald Trump delivered it is the
Keystone to a booming economy it's the
first thing he has to do first thing he
will do yeah can I ask how do you think
Trump is going to handle uh criticisms
he has about Co and when when Co first
you know hit us we didn't know what was
going on there were the initial
lockdowns I think this is something that
a lot of you know never trumpers or
Democrats or even moderates have
questions about uh it seemed like at one
time this was something that he was I'm
going to jump in real quick here cuz we
had this conversation when Laura lummer
and luuk rowski were on the show in uh
in Iowa and so now you've got these just
like I don't know winging cop fants on
social media misrepresenting what I said
and so you have Laura lomer blaming
Ronda santz saying he he locked
everything down it was really bad you
have Lukowski saying Donald Trump locked
everything down it was really bad and my
point
is everyone in the beginning of this
everyone got it wrong Republicans at the
start of covid were advocating wearing
masks and fouchi said not to and then
fouchy flip-flopped and all of a sudden
Republicans were saying don't wear masks
Donald Trump said 15 days to slow the
spread Donald Trump uh uh pushed
operation warp speed personally I look
back and I'm like yeah and Ronda Sanz
was also for mandates and lockdowns too
I don't see the point in having this
Trump is bad no Ron is bad no Trump is
bad back and forth over and over again
to try and adjudicate something happed
four years ago between two guys who did
relatively similar things or in
different ways Trump wasn't a governor
he didn't have control over the states
Ronda Sanz believed a lot of the same
garbage everyone else did and what
people did was they took this clip to
try to imply that I'm somehow saying
fouchy should not go to prison prison I
think I think Fouch is directly
responsible and he should go to jail I
should I think he should be criminally
charged and investigated of course but
it's it's silly in my opinion to attack
Donald Trump or Ronda santis when we
look back four years later we're like oh
now that we understand the origins and
now we have the evidence and now we
realize who is right and who is wrong
and who's who's responsible it's like oh
well you know now we go back and argue
that Trump should have done something
different well you should have but what
did anybody know at the time do you
think this is kind of how the Trump
campaign is responding to these you I I
studi polls as part of what I do and
even though we all feel strongly about
it when you stack it up next to
immigration and War and the economy it's
not moving that many voters I mean Trump
he relied on the doctors he's not a
doctor yeah he relied on the doctors
that's how I felt about this argument
for a long time that I mean we still get
it from the Democrats that abortion is
going to be the big issue of 2024 and it
just doesn't seem to be especially at
least in the primary season among
conservative voters uh maybe in a
general when you have to face up against
maybe moderates it'll be different but
there are so many things that they bring
forward saying well this is a potential
weakness you know this is this is a a
dent in the chain mail kind of thing and
it seems like no one can actually find
the thing that is irritating voters in a
way that would would uh impede the Trump
campaign I think the covid talking
points of trump are a cope for people
who just don't like Trump and are
looking for a reason to justify why they
wouldn't vote for him I'm concerned
about his stat issues with you know the
dude with the big mustache that got us
into yeah John Bolton wanted to take
over Iran um and he F and Bolton is just
out some of these horrendous Staffing
decisions that Don made and then the the
fouchy thing just giving he didn't give
him Authority but he basically stood
behind him and nodded while fouchy ran
the show he would do that with some
other technocrat in the future like the
CEO of Google he's like I'm not a social
media guy so I'm going to let the social
media guy run like yo the doctor should
be relying on the president to make the
right decision after their advice is
given not the other way around well
that's quite literally what happened the
other way was the other way around Trump
was relying on fouchy to make the right
call and basically he like whatever you
say is going to be a yes so good luck go
for it well we don't know that's
absolute that's what it looked like know
that he had Burks and fouchy up on stage
and it was uh uh you know in with them
all the time and it was a mistake in
hindsight and there are people who are
like I always knew exactly what was
going to happen be ass dude so many of
these uh Wing pundits were were
screaming bu masks bu masks now I had
people mailing me masks early on at the
start of this thing when it was March
and Donald Trump said 15 days slow the
spread and we understand these things
were scrips I just think when you look
at how good things were cons especially
considering the weights they stripped on
his ankles what I hear from you know
some of these individuals who are like I
won't vote for Trump because of what he
did on Co I'm like no new Wars spare me
your libertarian winging when you're
like my justification for why I won't
vot for Trump is some arbitrary thing
about mistakes that were made even
though he's the first president in our
lifetimes to not start a war and to
actually set a timeline to bring our
troops back and to negotiate with these
these countries like North Korea and to
try and get our troops out of Syria
setting a deadline for Afghanistan was
fantastic the Abraham Accords all of
these things were tremendous
achievements and then you're like but
because he wasn't so uh you know because
he made bad decisions at a time when you
know nobody knew exactly what was going
on I won't vote for him now and I'm like
dude if
if everything he did with Co it was it
was a lot of mistakes were made I
totally get that fair point Fair
criticism but the idea that that is
justification for why you would not vote
for him now with Biden here or
potentially Michelle Obama when you know
they're going to massively expand
foreign war Ukraine now the largest
recipient of US foreign aid and young
people can't afford Apartments but
they're smuggling humans in giving them
Healthcare giving them houses and then I
hear these people go but Trump made a
bad call on Co and I'm like yeah well
okay dude no one knew it was going on at
the time we can rag on it now but
there's such a tremendous Gap in what
Trump represents coming to this country
if you vote for him now versus what the
Democrats will do to this country if you
don't and that's what frustrates me it's
an excuse of people who will make an
argument every single day Trump was
right about this he was right about this
he was right about this he was right
about this okay will you vote for him
well because of Dr fouchy no get out of
here dude that's a lie that's Trump
derangement syndrome dude think about
how many things he hasn't done wrong you
know what I mean like think about how
the fact they were like investigating
this dude for years and they didn't come
up with anything they were like
literally trying to find anything they
didn't come up with anything like that's
that for me that's what cell say like
there's like two or three or four or
five things that everyone talks about
it's like in comparison to so many other
people for me that's what sells to me
like the dude seems like you saying like
because they he was persecuted legally
for so long they were trying to find
something want to lobby for him harder
yeah I mean I just see it as like if
they're trying to put this guy in and
they can't find any screw to drive home
but they're still willing to go yeah and
they're so they're going they trying so
hard they have to make up lies and stuff
about this dude it's like dude I mean
yeah there's a couple things that wrong
with him I agree about Bolton and stuff
like that but like man that's impressive
yeah so my view is like oh was Trump a
perfect candidate that's ridiculous
ridiculous to to assume was Trump a good
president he was the best president of
my life and I don't know I don't Roger
you're a lot older than I am but I agree
I didn't know I know much about Clinton
I didn't know I I knew about Bush and
that's when I was growing up seeing all
this stuff and so really my my what I
know about the presidency
is Bush holy crap bad Obama wow was I
lied to bad Donald Trump comes in wow
these are the things that people were
claiming were supposed to happen under
Joe Biden happening under Donald Trump
unemployment R rates were dropping in
minority communities young people were
seeing opportunity the rent was going
down I mean wages were going up uh
businesses were offering up 4day work
weeks there was this great list where
people were saying all these socialists
claim to want these things higher pay
better salaries uh um profit sharing
4-day work week and those were happening
under Trump through capitalism not not
socialism and now people are like yeah
but uh once in a-lifetime weird pandemic
thing happened where Dr fouchy did a
bunch of bad stuff so therefore Trump's
Trump's at fault and it's like I'm not
going to blame Trump for that yeah I
only bring it up just to ask like there
are obviously going to be criticism of
trump I'm not super tied to the co one
there are always with any candidate
going to be things that people look back
on the Legacy and say hey this is where
you lose me this is maybe the thing I
have concerned about and of course any
politician is going to have to address
them that's normal right you have to
answer questions from the voters they're
maybe not even hostile uh and so for you
know covid abortion immigration you know
whatever there are going to be things
the Trump campaign theoretically has to
address now that we're going into a
general election it looks like he'll be
the nominee I don't really think Nikki
Haley's going to uh turn the ship around
and so it's just interesting to hear how
the ca campaign decides to address these
things yeah it's a and it's definitely a
warning for the future if another like
um you know Global pandemic or issue
happens like there's a power outage the
system goes down the only one that can
save it is Google because the Google has
the access to the infrastructure to get
us back on our knees back on our feet
quick let's get the CEO of Google in to
help us run this s like no that cannot
happen next time
next time maybe they'll be an adviser
the technocrats can advise our
leadership but we need to at least look
at the fouchy situation as a learning
lesson that's a luk that's a LCM for
sure that's your point um and uh I think
that you can lay the blame at the feet
of trump but that's not a deal breaker
whether or not the vote for the guy
you're looking for the least worst
candidate anyway but like Roger you what
candidates did you serve over the years
or what administrations have you served
with I I worked for obviously for Nixon
I worked for Ronald Reagan 3 campaign 76
80 and 84 uh I worked for Senator Bob
doe I worked on the bush recount kind of
regr regretted that and of course Donald
Trump so you like skipped the clintons
the bushes I'm a republican so yeah was
that just like were you like avoiding
the war parties or were you always just
following your heart I I supported Bob
do in 1996 I held my nose and voted for
John McCain that was an error uh when
when the Republicans nominated Mitt
Romney I left the Republican party I
became a member of the libertarian party
I supported Gary Johnson uh because m
was so completely repugnant to me was
such a complete fraud and then I
returned to the Republican party in time
for the Hostile take over the Party by
Donald Trump who snatched the party back
from the country clubs and made it the
party of working Americans again ah yeah
feels like he's a liberal dude I always
thought of him as like a New York
Democrat I'm shocked some people thought
that early on but it turns out to be the
Heritage Foundation had a great report
he when it comes to actual policy he was
more conservative than Ronald Reagan did
you just see these presidents is like
the corruption within the systems like
with the Obamas with the clintons did
you like from afar just like or did were
you just not interested I mean uh my you
know it evolved over time so I wrote a
book on the Kennedy assassination which
I always had a Fascination about but it
wasn't until I got an opportunity to
talk to Nixon about it and I asked him
about the warring commission he said are
you kidding me it was the biggest
goddamn hoax in American history uh and
I said what do you mean he said well
Lyndon and I both wanted to be president
the difference was I wouldn't wasn't
willing to kill for it wow that that
motivated me to write my book which
became a New York Times bestseller the
man who killed Kennedy case against LJ
no publisher would touched this they
said nobody's going to read this book
this book has no Commercial Appeal wow
it it continues to do extraordinarily
well so I used to be one of those
Republican good Democrat bad lock step
look I now realize we have a uni party
so despite the Deep sentimental
attachment I have to the party of
Lincoln and the the party of Eisenhower
and the party of Nixon and Reagan and
Trump I also recognize that we have a
uni party at the elite level not at the
Grassroots level but at the elite level
we have one party of incumbent
politicians in Washington and they're
all in it together and that's the sad
Truth uh and and all of this posturing
is like a hegelian device to to distract
us from the fact that they're all the
same with the exception of one guy I
know Donald Trump how do you advise
people to like pioneer this environment
of a uni party or to survive it or even
in the from the political perspective or
just from the average it's very very
difficult to start a new party people
say why don't we just start a new party
well the people who write the laws about
getting a party on the ballot are
Republicans and Democrats working
together to make it as expensive and
Arcane and complicated and difficult as
possible so if you believe as I do that
the Republican party is a traditional
home of conservatives then we have to
win intraparty contests to nominate good
men and
women too many of the Republicans that
we have are rhinos I guess as as you'd
call it and we take a look at we had a
we had a list pulled up of the people
who voted to oust George Santos and I
called some of them scumbags and it's
funny because you're sitting here with a
member we're sitting here with a member
of Congress and he's like I know those
guys like I know some of these guys I'm
just like look Santos was not convicted
of anything
he's been accused and they removed him
already because his Republicans are
spineless so with the Supreme Court
ruling on the border a lot of people are
pointing out that Democrats will
Democrat judges will justify whatever it
is they want to do and tell you too bad
cry about it Republican judges will say
we're going to give to the Democrats
because we're fair and magnanimous and
it results in the Democrats just
steamrolling ahead and getting whever
they
want I like that George Santos guy you
like him yeah I didn't know that I would
and then I watched a video of him and I
was like this gu well he's entertaining
but but he was denied due process you're
right why throw the guy out before he
was convicted of anything he got thrown
out when he was only accused this isn't
how the system is going to work Adam
Clayton Powell got thrown out of
Congress by the Democrats only when he
was convicted of a crime it's the way it
should be I'm not particularly a fan of
of Santos nor am I particularly a Critic
of him but I I I do think he was denied
due process unlike Jamal Bowman right
who was convicted of pulling the fire
alarm
disrupting trying to disrupt a vote and
he gets to remain in Congress it seems
like these yeah it's kind of ridiculous
and I think it's sort of frustrating
that this is not something that the
Republicans and Congress aren't willing
to push harder on I mean it seems like
an inequal application of Justice we're
going to go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
it's the most powerful way to uh help
the show grow it it's really true just
telling your friends about it or playing
it when they're around if it's
appropriate and head over to
timcast.net the live shows we're putting
on if you think we do a good job in uh
the message we spread and everything
else become a member because it just it
keeps the lights on Clint Torres he's
back with the first Super Chat saying
howdy people how does he do it how does
Clint always get the first Super Chat in
he's good he he has a gift alphat turkey
says it's treason
then yep but I don't think treason is
the is the right word I think sedition
is the is the appropriate term correct
What specifically were you talking about
I'm not sure oh oh I'm sorry the the
Border Biden facilitating the uh the O
open border would be a seditious act
which is to destroy the government
whereas treason would be more aiding and
abetting an enemy well as you know the
House Republicans have declined to move
articles of impeachment against mayorcas
on that basis
alone just won't do
it their election of Duty just won't do
it man we have a unip party
sadly yes I'm afraid so that's that
doesn't mean obviously that everybody in
the Republican party is bad I think for
example for example Rand Paul who I
think's a very very good guy and a very
principled guy there are good people
yeah uh there but it is a it's a
corrupting system you get elected to
congress you show up you have great
intentions you got great beliefs when
you get there then you realize it's a
money Chase you're spending all your
time in the house raising money for your
next reelection uh and people introduce
you to lobbyists who in turn introduce
you to other lobbyists and pretty soon
it's all about how much is in your bank
account would you want to change the
length of house terms then because I've
heard that before because they're
basically as soon as you get I think we
need term limits first of all I I think
three terms in the house six years is
enough I think two terms in the Senate
12 years that's pretty long frankly
right yeah and like what are you going
to what else are you going to do if
you're if you're contributing society
and stuff like that how can you really
represent people if you don't know what
the outside world you become completely
out of touch all you do is politics it's
all you know well and but and the voters
are overwhelmingly in favor of term
limits which the politicians will never
let this happen because they're
destroying their they're destroying
their livelihood yep yeah they like the
system the way it is yeah the emperor's
Champion says what makes people think
that all of these criminal migrants
would stay if a civil war breaks out
they have no loyalty to the US why
wouldn't they flee it depends depends on
how it goes down but I can imagine a
scenario where Donald Trump gets elected
says I'm going to start uh deportation
process for these criminal aliens and
then in major Urban cities they come out
and say we will defend you but you have
to defend yourself and then you actually
have them saying we won't leave
Democrats are going to argue you have a
right to be here you're immigrants
you've been given your proper
documentation Trump is committing a
crime don't let him do it and then if
there is fighting that breaks out the
illegal immigrants be fighting with
Democrats like fighting on the side of
MH yeah all
right let's grab some more Super chats
YouTube's been giving us the business
with super chats it's kind of annoying
all right Paul tascal says half measures
cause cause full failures Abbott waited
2 and a half years his plan was destined
to lose in court now we get Biden wins
and immigration headlines 70 dudes in a
park with cattle ran supplies isn't
stopping 300,000 illegal illegal
immigrants per
month yes
unfortunately Scott Marshall says one
Strickland definitely got robbed two
Abbott should ignore the Supreme Court
and defend the Texas border three if you
aren't playing pal world then you're
missing out is it the Pokemon with guns
game I have not heard of that that
sounds cool though yeah it's basically
Pokemon with guns uh Abbott should I
don't know if ignore the Supreme Court
is the right way to phrase it the
Supreme Court ruling the feds can remove
barricades means nothing when Texas
National Guard are not feds anywhere
near the barricades and technically if
the federal government doesn't order
them to do it they're allowed to but
they're still not going to do it because
they weren't ordered to do it the real
issue is that the Supreme Court would
have to order the Texas National Guard
to vacate allowing the uh feds to come
into the Border but this ruling saying
they're allowed to remove barriers
doesn't mean they're allowed to remove
Texas National Guard so right now it's
it's legal limbo I guess MH and the
question of uh how B how many people
they have to to staff this project right
I mean doesn't this the razor wire
extend for like several miles right and
if and if they do remove the Razer wire
does the ruling say Texas can't put more
can't does does the ruling stop Texas
from putting Razer wire up yeah so
imagine the feds come in and actually
remove a bunch and then start as they're
moving it it's just being instantly
replaced by Texas the question will be
if the Supreme Court says Texas can no
longer place the the the
wire Greg duvier says Tim VI need to be
VP so we can have vake versus uh Kamala
VP debate it will be the most one-sided
debate
ever what would that be vake debating
kamla
Harris it be rough it'd be rough I don't
think he would have enough to work with
right like he's such a quick witted
person I feel like he needs someone who
can Spar a little bit more to have
something going on and I think she
doesn't really have uh anything to offer
on the debate stage in my opinion I mean
she is just it wouldn't be a debate it
it'd be her standing there with drool it
would be a Slaughter is what it he'd
have to have restraint and be kind cuz
if he got angry if he got malicious that
would be the the media spin be like what
an right he was mean to her yeah
I don't know he's got to learn to pull
punches all right Donald Dev says Tim
you are being too hard under santis
about the supposed Winston Churchill
quote at the end of Darkest Hour a movie
about Churchill before the credits they
they show that same quote and attribute
it to Churchill however there is an
historical organization that says that's
not true that it was never attributed to
him and that it is attributed uh uh and
then someone else pointed out it's a
Budweiser Ed from 1938 so do we think
it's just like a staffer saw this movie
and was like I know the perfect quote to
close on but like the point is this I
understand people Miss attribute that
quote to
Churchill the issue is you should have a
staff fact check this because it only it
only takes a couple minutes to figure
out that's not a Church Hill quote it
was misattributed yeah well somebody
looked at it and they thought it fit the
situation perfectly and then they didn't
do their homework and now you've got
Ronda santis quoting Budweiser and he
can't get fired right I mean the
campaign's over so whoever wrote this is
already out of a job yeah that's
right Wyatt cinberg says the first Civil
War was over Democrats wanting slaves as
cheap labor the second Civil War will be
over Democrats wanting illegals for
cheap
labor I don't think it's about cheap
labor I think it's destruction and
subversion of the system which they have
publicly stated dramatically altering
this country to benefit
themselves all right here we
are TRD says Abbott's wire solution
remove it then allow Texas volunteers to
replace it it would technically be in
compliance because Texas government
didn't reinstall it yes but I don't I
don't know that the supreme court
ordered it be removed they they the
ruling was that the feds can remove it
correct I mean I the Fed I mean the
federal government is allowed to remove
it pending the rest of this legal case
so if it goes back in they would still
have the right to remove it it's not a
permanent solution but the right to
remove it doesn't mean they have a right
to remove National Guard yeah if the
National Guard were to block them from
having access to it then that's
different but theoretically in this case
if a volunteer installed it they would
still be allowed it's not you can only
REM remove razor wire installed by the F
the state government it's any razor
that's there you're allowed to remove
Ian fter says Tim longtime subscriber
here you should invite Greg conon he's
an attorney and president of American
vaping Association you would be
fascinated at the harm corruption lies
the FDA and states are spewing right now
about vaping and the health benefits of
it I heard this really interesting uh uh
pitch one time that really candidates
should Lobby for The Vape vote and they
should really like the that people who
Vape across all sections of um you know
political classes and socioeconomic
classes and if you could just get all of
the people who Vape to get behind your
candidate you would have this kind of
Coalition of diverse voters I found that
like very I find people who Vape there
is a high I I wouldn't I'm not going to
try and blanket everybody but I find a
very high rate of what's the right word
they're rude
inconsiderate um in a certain area and
that is I am actually
surprised at people who will Vape inside
someone else's uh home or or or business
or vehicle knowing what they're doing is
bothering them trying to hide it but
doing it anyway without asking I've
experienced this so often from from
people who Vape now I certainly have
experienced I agree people who Vape who
don't they won't do it they'll be like
hey can I can I run out I'm going to
vape I'm like oh yeah yeah no problem
but we've had in many instances here in
this building vaping is not allowed it
is uh uh uh contractual there's there's
a bunch of stuff behind it I'm not going
to get into we cannot allow people to
vape or smoke in the building it doesn't
matter so people will actually take
small Vapes and hide them and try and
vape in here despite their being signed
saying don't do it when they come in we
say don't do it we get it it sucks but
nothing we can do about it there's legal
issues and they do it anyway I I got to
be honest I'm really at the point where
it's like we've had people come on the
show and when they think I'm not paying
attention like I'll look down at the
monitor I'll see them take their hand
like this and
go and then they won't talk for a little
bit and then when I look check the M go
and then I'm just I'm at the point where
I'm like I'm going to throw someone out
who will be sitting in this guest chair
who pulls out a vape to try and pull it
off and I'm just going to be like bro
get up you get up like that's it it's
like it's it's like spinning on me like
dude I don't care about vaping I get it
but we you can't there's a big sign
saying don't do it they know we don't
want them to do it we ask them not to do
it they don't care well it reminds me of
just sort of a lack of common courtesy
right like people are sort of less
polite they are less considerate it's
like I well I really really really want
to do this thing so I should be allowed
to do it if you don't see it it's okay
and ultimately that's not a way to
operate that seems like the degradation
of society in all honesty I don't think
there are
many single issue Vape voters in other
words you're right it crosses many
barriers but I don't know anyone who's
motivated by that issue in terms of the
reason they would cast their vote I mean
the come Prett hard on vaping you yeah
in your cars it's like hey we're get
food hop in and then they're sitting in
the back start vaping I'm like bro are
you kidding me open the window what are
you doing that's the worst it's just
come on man I mean I think some people
who Vape I don't do it I can't ascribe
to the culture but you know there are
some people who Vape who feel the
dependency because I remember when juel
uh for a minute was going to get banned
from the market I knew people who drove
out and bought it in bulk because they
didn't want to be without it I mean
there is a there is a habit forming
element of it I just don't think that
like it should Trump in this case
especially like this being an example
you're not allowed to do it in here the
fact that you would be like but I'm just
going to make an exception for myself is
is discus and it's it's just it happens
all the time like look guys like it
happens once or twice and I was just
like hey hey you can't Vape in here they
go oh okay but it's happened probably
like 37 times which is just like yo this
is nuts we had someone come in recently
actually point to the sign and be like
oh we can't Vape in here yeah okay five
minutes later like and I'm like wow that
was the last draw for me the last person
who did was a couple weeks ago I was
like I think from now on we're going to
put out like put out a message I just I
just kind of feel like such a dick move
to do that we're just going to ask you
to leave and like I'll literally put Mr
bcus in that chair and we'll do the show
with whoever's in the house because just
like bro if you want to come in here and
just basically spit in my face you can
leave you don't need to be here that's
that's the whole vaping thing to me you
can tell it's been it's been irking me
for some time that people keep doing
this and it's like at the 37th time I'm
just finally like bro that's it it comes
up up there we go I'm going to talk
about it no but I think it's like I
think it is picking up on something that
I I really feel In America which is that
there's a a sort of uh there is an
inherent selfishness to the way we live
now and I think it's uh aided and eded
by consumerist and sort of social media
culture that says I have to think about
my needs above everything else and I
think if we moved away from that we
would be a better and stronger
Society all right Mr grizzly bear says
Tim what's stopping Biden from declaring
what Texas is doing a Reb and
federalizing the Texas guard what do you
think are the chances of it and what
could the repercussions be I don't know
the chances Democrats are actually
already talking about it I think it was
walking Castro perhaps there's an
article we had pulled up we didn't get
into it but they are talking about
federalizing the National
Guard y if the Biden Administration
tried basically seizing control of Texas
National Guard that's like over this
issue particularly that may be like the
most Civil War e thing I could think of
at the moment the fed's coming down and
being like from now on you will take
orders from us and no one
else that's wild and I there there's
there's a possibility of they're
actually discussing doing that we'll see
man I honestly don't know what do you
think the likelihood of that is you
think that's I think it is unlikely yeah
I think it is unlikely certainly it's
certainly not desirable I
agree man I don't know all right random
Eskimo says if we can afford to send
$200 billion to Ukraine for a war we
illegally caused through Boris Johnson
we can afford to use our own National
Guard to remove illegal
Invaders yeah the Ukraine stuff is a
mess I just want to make sure every
young person knows that's all you got to
do go to Every gen Z kid and be like hey
can you afford an apartment and they go
no and be like did you ask why it is
Democrats are sending hundreds of
million hundreds of billions of dollars
to a foreign country have you asked why
Democrats are giving illegal immigrants
Free Housing hey look man I get it you
can't afford a place to live that's
wrong you should our younger generation
needs to be able to have families and
buy homes have you you ask yourself why
it is that Joe Biden is bringing in
illegal immigrants and then giving and
then the Democrats in New York are
putting them up in hotels you know these
hotel rooms have a bed and a bathroom
and they expect you to live in a
bachelor micro apartment or a pod you're
an American citizen 20 years old trying
to find an apartment you're going to
school the best you can find is for
$2,000 in New York a micro apartment
congratulations that illegal immigrant
who came here they put him up in a fancy
hotel in the Upper West Side of New York
where he's got his own big bed to in his
own
bathroom sorry sucks for you I guess
you're being left out vote Trump I can
tell you this I can't guarantee Trump's
going to solve all those problems but I
can tell you if you vote Democrat
they'll only make it worse so it's you
choose it's on you
man all right the lion says Tim I can
tell you're not a UFC fan decis
decisions are controversial 70% of the
time when you're the Challenger it's
said to not leave it to the hands of the
judges Strickland won rounds one two and
five by the way that apparently how the
media scored it it's how a lot of people
watching online were scoring it as it
went they're like oh man that round
easily went to uh I remember watching it
and I'm seeing people tweet like rounds
one and two easily went to Strickland
and I'm like man I don't know it just
looks like he's winning and then in the
end they're like the other guy wins and
I was like huh and it's you know look
confirmation bias it's all I need as
soon as I watched that clip of Joe Rogan
acting surprised I was like see I'm
right my my what bothers me is look I'm
just some Layman
I don't watch UFC fights all that often
but sometimes I've been watching them
now because I'm a fan of these Fighters
because they're standing up for the
people and pushing back on the machine
and I watch a fight happen I see
something I understand and they call it
for a guy who doesn't appear to win the
fight it seems like not a sport I should
be interested in watching later on
because I'm like if it is it just fake
you know like people so so I tweeted
that I'd rather just watch two guys go
in the fight ends when the fight ends
but I think it's a Fair Point people
made like they've tried that in the past
it doesn't work you get people just
spinning around in circles for an hour
and nothing happens and everyone's like
what is this no one's even fighting so I
understand that rounds are to basically
put pressure on but then if you do
rounds you need a scoring system but I'm
just like if it comes down to this they
should at the very least say that a win
requires a point spread of like 10 or
something in which case if you're on
round five and it's like this you go
around again they look at the judge and
the judges say we do not have a
definitive answer it's a split decision
round six oo that'd be rough yep would
be cuz they give it every they time it
knowing that there's only going to be
five rounds so they'll come in with
everything and people have complained
about this that you end up with Fighters
specifically trying to win on
technicalities through rounds instead of
actually winning a fight and so so it
becomes more of a game and that's that's
a part of it I guess you know I I was
reading about this one guy I forgot his
name he was saying he wants to see a
fight he wants to see the best F guy
fight the best guy instead when you
start introducing these rules to try and
condense things and make something
watchable you end up with people just
exploiting the rules for maximum points
to win Combat Sports especially is very
unique in that there's no ball like you
can't count how many times did the ball
hit the the net how many times did the
ball pass by the line because then it's
objectively we already know who won
you've got like dudes trying to qualify
the behaviors of the athletes and that's
the that's the score and so they try and
do like strikes is it a is it a
significant strike is it a is it is a
light and if it was just like how many
hits did you get then you get light Jabs
but it's like okay so we got a way
significant so they try I can respect
that they try to come up with the
scoring system that makes sense but the
problem is you end up watching a fight
like the Strickland fight and it's clear
a guy won but you know one thing I'm
seeing a lot of people say is dupi took
got got six out of six out of 11
takedowns Strickland had none and so I I
I watch dupi take him down he he grabs
him throws him on the ground and I'm
like oh wow that's that's bad but but
it's like not not that there's no damage
there's no control and so apparently
people are saying the takedowns this is
the comment commentary I'm seeing for
people who are in favor of Strickland it
said the judges weighed the the
takedowns way too heavily as if that was
significant when it wasn't he knocked
him down Strickland got right back up
got out of it kept fighting that's
different than a takedown that leads
into like some sort of uh control like
sub yeah but I think takedowns are good
you know and he he did knock Strickland
down that's great but if I was watching
that fight in the street I'd just be
like wow Strickland is beating that guy
up a takedown and a knockdown should be
counted differently a knockdown where
the guy goes down and you're looking at
him and he's on the ground whereas a
takedown is where you bring him to the
ground and have control of him on the
ground that would be I would think worth
more points than a
knockdown it is what it is I just it
frustrates me because I'm just like I
don't I don't I don't I don't want to
watch a fight where I'm counting points
and trying to map things out I want to
see guys fight you know anyway David gon
says Tim I'm five minutes from Maryland
Live Arundle rhymes with bundle by the
way I still have that metal momento myy
mask for you oh very cool Maryland Live
is is a lot of fun a lot of fun we we
were hanging out there and they got like
a nice little bar and some lady was
singing good times good times all
right dad's didn't flag says Tim and Co
can you please shout out my amazing wife
gadon flag girl from the Austin show and
our new baby our little girl was born
last month is a true blessing and
growing strong we cannot wait to take on
this crazy world as a family of four
That's so exciting congratulations it's
cool I love when people call in and be
like I have had a baby like I just want
everyone to do it every day
yeah Tom kaves says I just it just came
out that a GOP chairman Jeff dwit was
the one that went to K Lake's house and
attempted to bribe her into quitting
politics she said this was done in a
previous speech have you heard about
that I have what's going on with that uh
the there was Iona Republican party
dominated by the Rhinos is epically
corrupt I've never seen a more clear-cut
absolute proof of a fraudulent election
in the 45 years I've been doing this and
no judge wants to accept this evidence
and no judge wants to rule uh uh
honestly that's really simple you have a
tabulating machine it takes a piece of
paper that is uh that is 19 in long we
test it with 19in ballots the next day
the ballots that are in are 20 in of
course the tabulator is going to spit it
back out and after three times they say
oh just go put your ballot in that box
over there we'll count it later I'm
simplifying it but the manipulation of
the Arizona election was we got to make
sure outage it was also long lines
caused by the errors some people went
home right and then they came out and
said no one went home what do you mean
no one went home there are people who
have tweeted they went home like it's
none of that matters any Judge worth his
weight in his own balls would say the
machines were broken you screwed up new
election shut your mouth instead you get
a bunch of cowards who are like well we
all know the machines were broken but I
don't want to be the one to take
responsibility for this this is what you
have you have weak men weak men in this
country who are unwilling to actually
stand up and say I'm sorry I have to and
and you know what man it's a bummer I'm
waiting for one of these Texas Troopers
or national Guardsmen to arrest one of
these CBP guys you know what I want to
see I want to see when one of these feds
tries to remove the barrier from Texas I
want to see a Texas trooper walk right
up and say put your hands behind your
back you are under arrest for
destruction of felony destruction of
State Property carries a a minimum of
one year and a $2,500 fine and then reom
his wres lock him up I don't care who
breaks the law you break the law you get
arrested that's how it's supposed to
work but too many of these people just
go I don't want to be the one to do it
oh don't put it on me I I'm I'm willing
to bet most of these Texas Troopers if
they saw the feds breaking the law they
just frug and be like I don't know I
what am I going to do there's but but
I'll tell you I'll tell you what you saw
that viral video of the firefighter
getting arrested this is why this is why
you ended up with Trump supporters
throwing the the B the the uh The Thin
Blue Line flag on the ground and
stomping on it a few years ago because
you get a video where a firefighter
Parks the fire truck at an angle so that
it creates a barrier as they're
rendering Aid to a guy who's in a car
accident and a cop yells at him to move
the firet truck and they say like we're
rendering Aid so this a viral video cop
arrests the firefighter oh great so you
get the FBI going into bubble Wallace's
garage because they found a garage pull
rope meanwhile the feds are quite
literally facilitating human smuggling
operations and there's not a man with a
spine or a set of balls in sight to tell
them to
stop and this is what you will get in
this country everybody wants to take the
path of lease resistance a cop says
look if I go and try and stop these
federal law enforcement off officers
from breaking the law it's going to jam
me up I'm cause me a lot of problems I'm
going to ignore it ah here's a lwh
hanging fruit a firefighter who's parked
his fire truck on the side of a highway
who's trying to render Aid to somebody
nothing bad will happen to me well
granted that guy got sued apparently
it's an older story and uh people have
brought that up but this is what's
frustrating is that for for a lot of
these cops there's no risk to pulling a
guy over and giving him a speeding
ticket if he wasn't even speeding well
you know what you may have been speeding
I don't know maybe it was the other car
I'll give you a ticket you deal with it
but then when they actually witness
something that's actually a threat to
them they don't want to do it Lukowski
talked about this in New York there was
a guy stabbing people on the train and
the cops were like I'm not getting
involved in that sure but you know if
some guy jumps a Turn Style they're
going to run him down and they're going
to use Force against him no that guy
should get arrested don't get me wrong
or he should get a ticket or whatever
the fine is but then when things
actually get hot we have no strong men
in sight to actually try and deal with
the problem this is why I was saying I
like UFC cuz these guys are using the
platform they have telling the machine
to screw off at risk to themselves that
that I respect to go back to your
question I have to say Carrie lake is
one of the most impressive talents I've
ever seen as a communicator as a person
since not since I work for Reagan have I
seen anyone that good that talented uh
she's extraordinary she's going to have
a great future I think she got cheated
uh she's still fighting over that
election while she's running for the
Senate but she is a she's the future
without any
question
I love her man all right the real Hydro
PX says Tim I will give you 10K if you
take an IQ test I here's an IQ test
sending me over
$200 while telling me you'll give me a
$10,000 to take an IQ test I think you
failed no but shout out we love real
Hydro he just rags in the super chats
all day every day and I want to give you
a shout out because I think you legit
spent like $200 today ragging on ragging
on me mostly and uh I'm actually
watching like the Super Chat Revenue
just going up as Hydro just Rags over
and over again I'm like he's so
supportive of us it's great I don't know
what to think like he's insulting me but
giving me money at the same time like
what do you do a guy walks up to you and
he hands you a $5 bill and calls you
dumb you're like okay you're like this
happens me all the time so people will
go to Cameo and they say you're a
Russian Trader in a piece of and a
dummy I'm a dummy I just got 200 bucks
from you who's dumb but I don't know I
like yeah okay I accept I accept your
terms sir thank you for the Super Chat I
appreciate it man but also I'll look
you're allowed to insult me and if you
want to spend money to to to have it
done like okay you know I don't read
everybody super chats uh you know all
right Phil dude bro says why is nobody
saying DeSantis passes a six six- week
abortion ban and that is cryptonite for
swing States how would he be able to do
battle to how would he be able to battle
the media on that
issue I have no idea I I do think it is
not palatable to voters I do think it
would be a it would be what been
problematic had he gotten to a general
election uh I think you could be
pro-life but not be that radical uh I
think it was uh you know look the guy
says he signs an executive order which
prohibits the school boards uh in
Florida from teaching a curriculum that
includes CRT or any of this gender
nonsense sounds great it's a great fres
Le is a great announcement but not in
the county where I live where they're
doing it right now and in the seven
largest counties well where's the
governor been he's been in Iowa so yeah
it sounds good but it has no reality in
terms of
enforcement all right Brian forsaken as
the world crumbles says so what's the
prediction if we lose the house the
Senate and the
presidency um start digging a large hole
the guy who's like his screen name is
the world crumbles what do I do if
everything falls apart is the question
well jeez he going to look on the dark
side and ask what are you guys going to
do Tina is looking pretty good to me you
know I like Malay A lot's he's a he's a
friend of mine yeah and I actually
looked it up there's like 100 acres for
$4,000 in South Argentina and I was like
this sounds really good the only caveat
the only only way to get there is by
raft down a river and Tim let me tell
you something the best steak in the
world Argentina unbelievable oh wow well
that sounds great I was uh we were we
were hanging out um at this place that
they had like a heated pool and a hot
tub but there's snow everywhere it's in
PA and I'm hanging out with Richie
Jackson and uh there's like 2 and 1/2 ft
of snow next to the pool that's just
piled up they turn the heaters on in the
pool you can go in the pool and he digs
out a large hole cave into the into the
hole into the snow and then just looks
at me and says I think this is what men
are supposed to be doing to which
followed up shortly after by him yelling
out this is the best day of my life and
it was one of the funniest things ever
but I just bring that up because you
know you know men dig holes it's it's
just just a thing you know have you guys
seen the meme no it's just like for some
reason you start digging that's why Elon
Musk once he gets all this money what
does he do the boring company Jeff Bezos
what do he he digs into a giant he digs
into a mountain yeah Zu builds a thing
in Kawai whatever right yeah just start
digging a hole all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and head over to Tim cast.com
click join us become a member because
we're going to have a members only
uncensored show not so familyfriendly
coming up on the front page of the
website in a couple of minutes we're
talk about some spicy political issues
and uh it'll be good fun and you as
members will be able to call in and ask
us and our guests questions so it'll be
a lot of fun smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Roger do you want
to shout anything out uh let's make
America great again we got one more
chance this is it right on you have a
Twitter handle or a uh you can find me
Twitter Roger jstone jrjr I'm not on
Facebook so that guy who says he's Roger
Stone on Facebook who's selling crypto
that's me don't that's not me don't go
for it don't go for it I'm banned for
life on Instagram I'm banned for life on
Facebook I'm banned for life on YouTube
uh you can find me on Rumble at
rumble.com
rogerstone or X formerly known as
Twitter uh as Roger jstone Jr that's a
hilarious way to be like no that has to
be a fraud because I'm for Life uh I'm
Hannah Clair bmla I'm a writer for
cnr.com if you want to follow their work
you can follow timcast news on Twitter
and Instagram if you want to follow me
personally I'm on uh Twitter X whatever
it's called at hcbo and I'm on Instagram
at Hannah C.B guys thank you so much for
watching tonight thanks Ian thank you
for having me and thanks for coming
everyone at Ian cross and follow me on
the internet everywhere and I'll catch
you there good to see you man good to
meet you Roger yeah cheers uh Roger
thank you for doing the show appreciate
it uh yeah uh I'm surge.com I'm still
looking for that URL I have to figure it
out so um let's do that after show we
will see you all over at
timcast.net
that